on est pas mal on se voit de 4 4,5 m3
qui a essayé six femmes est peu trop bon
il ne suit pas les préceptes on va pas
l'écossaise
avec autant avoir intéressant
terrible
donc 40 scène je dirais à six
voies pas berline m
ainsi de jouer je suis étonné par par ce
choix du joueur russe fab
bah pourquoi pas hein
pourquoi tu joues
ah ouais bon bah j'ai envie de te dire
le match est déjà terminée fab
non mais j'ai espéré voir un truc un peu
original tu vois une écossaise
ouais ou une viennoise où j'enseigne
pont diani une italienne un peu
intéressante faille en a marre de ces
espagnols il va pas mieux joué qu'eux
que magnus de toute façon ils tendent
pas son va-tout qua
non dotés d un moment on
va avoir un refrain pas très bien joué
alors je sais pas pendant les heures ok
mais je sais pas je sais pas pourquoi je
vais essayer de choper takam sais pas
pourquoi elle n'est pas là ok il ya eu
un bug fab mais ajoute rien et ça a été
de retour en fait si on veut essayer
toutes les gammes donc étant on a quoi
comme cam on a une canne dessus bon ce
[Musique]
bon l'échiquier himer d'un les blancs
eurockéennes tourne justement remettre
en place un match comme ça
on en profite pour un peu tchèque toutes
nos gammes donc là c'est la cam 3 c sur
magnus ça peut partir en janvier
marcheurs une idée sur le marché
des dépôts comme sur le
battant mais on va toutes les faire on a
eu un bug avec ta cam sur le tracé est
magnifique je pense qu'on peut reste
aléatoire et ça là dessus
mais football magnifique
salle assez orné peau il n'a pas l'air
bien des points il joue h3 anti ont-ils
marshall enfin anti marche à 8 heures
c'est encore une qu'amener paumé plus en
somme
ce public c'est public
ce qu'il ya du monde
c'est pas
ça va être plein écran le public
alors plus tard on verra plus tard
et là il ya des commentateurs c'est
qu'ils
s'amendent
serait magnifique de laisser se
voit pas les joueurs amateurs c'est qui
la fille
je sais pas j'ai du mal on est un peu
long et là
c'est la solution ouais bon des forêts
clichy qui y voient un échiquier à côté
à sanaa un musée du chocolat
on met quelques âmes on mecam carlos n
va il est seul sur sur la partie très
néo cons ce concours de marche j'aurais
dû chronométrés quoi
peut-être ouvrir un nouvel échiquier
c'est vrai qu'on a on a une position qui
croit son pack ouais
ouais en fait j'aime bien le khalife 6 3
f à roybon serock
la foulée 3 rxh 3 est ce que c'est parce
que ba qui avait joué belge à 90 dont il
avait joué à 4,6 mais h 3
bon déjà carrier qui
en gros pour expliquer ce qu'ils savent
pas pourquoi je crois ici en général les
blancs le grand coup pendant des
décennies genre principal cc3 prépare
des quatre est ici des noirs en fait ils
ont deux options soit ils font des six
il joue plus classique en général les
blancs font h3 à ce moment là le nord
font ce qu'ils veulent genre qui avait
dit à 5 km et 8 peu importe mais ces
deux c5 des quatre
cd grandes mines anti green de
l'espagnol
juste une deuxième option l'une des six
sept chars des cinq ce qu'on appelle le
gambit marshall bon ça donne un pion et
5 il prend encore prend
et on faire food et si c'est
effectivement ça va pour les noirs après
on peut chercher à gagner qu'un pion de
plus ou quoi mais il ya vachement de jeu
et voilà et pour finir
je reviens en arrière jouer h3 d'abord
en fait l'idée des blancs c'est dire au
noir bat faux billets toujours un coût
des six ça paraît logique maintenant je
fais ces trois et je rentre dans l'antre
donc soit si green soit briarde
l'espagnol ou d'autres et que tours 8e
peu importe mais
je t'ai pas laisser jeu de marshall et
si jamais tu veux quand même un marshall
avec des cinq sur h3 avait bouffé le
pion mais c'est quand même plus digne
que je jouais h3 que ces trois là
puisque tu t'es pas affaibli la can tu
vas faire des trois c'est ça tu seras
pas affaibli quoi agacer mais les belges
aussi tu veux tu faire d'autres choses
voilà c'est ça l'idée de 1,3 après
princial donc les noirs ce qu'ils aiment
bien faire est fixé à 5a fait carré d as
un coin alors la question fab c'est
d'autres nouveautés car il est prendre 5
bat clairement
on est de regarder juste pour dire ce
qu'on se connaissait mois de base
s'était blessé à toute requête à 500
avec des dessins qui pouvaient partir
quand même
c'est pas une nouveauté et on a les
parties de qui a joué ça je pense pas y
trouver à
il aurait fallu que je prenne la tuer
demain faut qu'on s'organise pour te
mettre la turbine à messi à côté web un
mètre d'eau geste petites tables
d'appoint faut que d'aller chercher je
me cherchais une turbine atteint
on va t'en vas voir pour le moment je
vais essayer de choper les parties
hockey mondial 5 mon perso je
connaissais pas en fait
il a pris 1,25 tempo il connaît un
bon c'est bon signe qu'elle connaît yako
qu'un deuxième piste godoffe 35 parties
dans la base mais à ces correspondances
s'abaisse godoffe c'est quoi bon lui les
deux je devrais tourner sommes
ok mais c'est jamais joué au niveau ça
j'ai jamais vu que non mais j'ai jamais
vu non plus bas je connaissais pas mais
écoute ça peut être aussi les ordis qui
te disent qu'il ya un champ de
confrontation père de fou patati patata
on va voir ça intéressant en tout cas
là disons on voit la c'est une pression
fraîche
lacombe aquatinte ou plus avec les
blancs les noirs ont la peur de fous je
dois te faire fouler cette des singles
j'imagine ouais ça régale quand même
d'entrer fab se maintient avec une
nouveauté comme ça un peu surprenante
ouais
mais carlsen qui veut prendre
l'initiative et
intéressant donc oui mon cas les
prochains que pense tu es obligé quel
bilan fais tu as passé de revenir mais
un aveu de faiblesse incroyable de
prendre ce pion en réalité les noirs
normalement n'ont pas le temps de faire
cavalier à 5 c 5 pascal cure et cinq ans
prise donc s'ils peuvent faire cavalier
à 5 sur 8 à dire ça réfute quasiment h3
voilà donc en beauté j'étais obligé si
tu veux prétendre un avantage c'est
obligé de le prendre
bon c'est les coups les plus logiques un
fourbe et moi ce que je veux na c'est le
pion e4 donc il a fallu défendre par des
trois émanant des 5 c'est un petit peu
l'idée des noirs ils ont donné un pion
mais ils vont s'activer vous savez c'est
très visuel c'est un peu comme un
marshal justement avec toutes les pièces
bon ça c'est pas d'amener si ces dames
prend dé 5,1 évidemment le petit bug qui
vais bien fab vu ce que je veux attendre
l'annoncé
tombe bien
c'est le mouvement quoi ça me botte dont
qui a été redessiné ce qu'on a mais
trois
visuellement c'est un pion un ça va
changer d'âme bon c'est un pion contre
la paire de foot
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour un
dépôt en fait parce que je pense que si
ma news tout ça c'est que il a étudié au
fond et que ça doit aller je le vois pas
magnus une variante qui donne finale
pions - souffrance 1 quel intérêt
si tu rentres la dent de gaieté de coeur
en force
non mais oui mais ça va
parce que là il est rentré la bande de
gaieté de coeur
maazou mais chacun aura le coup qu'il a
joué comme ça
sur damas trois à temps
ceux ci soient
j'entraîne c'est de voir un
le fouillent landais si ces apéros
ceinture way gérard sendrey fin aussi
way céline numéro de turbine est si
mince et costauds quoi à
vis des roms
j'écoute je fais juste cavalli ces trois
genres admettons d'un point 5 dame prend
bessette et damages un an et dames 1
d'abord vous à ok salid en fait c'est
que sur dame 17,3 protège la tour
chrono ça donne mais ça fout des 6,3 f1
dont car il apprend le 5 dans le premier
set et la tour est protégée il ya quand
même dommage 2 mais c'est pas grave
parce que tu défends g2 tu pourras
toujours faire faut 3 couvrir la colonne
c'est a besoin sur les chaque tour à
tour ils ont des rêves 3g
qui tu vas quoi d'autre côté fait un
tabac
il a ajouté mme bomse mi6 tour fp8
mais là ça va être hyper chiant de
cliquer dans les fous qui voudraient par
les instructeurs français c'est réparé
choix ah non c'est vrai
mais c'est insupportable en fête a donc
des f3 food et
6,3 f1 tour fb 8 tempo c'est magnifique
parce que tu menace d'un poinçon gars
nous apprend mieux sauter ça
c'est magnifique ce raid sur wat ou
tempo ces prépas contre prépa mais c'est
clair que ça va oui mais non en fait si
ça allait pas les blancs connaîtraient
pas tombé dessus comme avec les blancs
c'est que cavaler à 5 tout le monde
savait que ça à égaliser
c'est magnifique
donc là l'idée c'est que maintenant
après d'un point 5 dans le premier set
on aurait d'emprunt échec pas prend un
tour pro b cette jeune homme prend
donc a priori les blondes doit faire de
m'apprendre à me servir
des 4 et à cette finale
pourquoi les blancs seraient pas mieux
juste dans mon cas je vois pas n'est pas
perdre ça
je sais pas gagné à la paire de fou ça
donne du jeu il essaie de faire ces cinq
c4 un jour
je sais pas mais je vois pas pourquoi un
dans quel monde tu es pas content avec
les blancs d'avoir ça t'as juste un pion
plus bon l'autre à la paire de fou mais
c'est quand même vraiment deux résultats
et j'ai l'impression que tu peux la
jouer pendant longtemps
d'ailleurs pas claire mais en tout cas
je jugerai pas ça comme étant dangereux
pour les besoins
en temps je veux c'est sûr que non mais
tu penses que c'est pas avantage clair
petit avantage clair non je sais pas
mais tu fais comment avec les non en
fait je veux juste faire cavalier c3 et
c'est d'échanger petit à petit les
pièces si je réussis à échanger sa
contre ça et ça contre ça je suis beau
quand même arme il va te faire ces 5 km
et 4
c 5 juste pour voir on va faire payer
ces trois
variables et 4
voilà puis je sais pas j'ai toujours
mieux
bon puisque beaucoup plus je fais rien
je sais pas trop comment avec le monde
doit s'y prendre je faire cavalier 2 je
sais que ça vous prend b
4e 4 il semblait 4 6 1 dans je sais que
tu donnes option a passé
je sais pas si long terme
si je prends là tu reprends de ces qui
peut envoyer à ouais non mais j'en sais
rien c'est juste pour dire que y'a un
truc mais
on va voir président serait
en fait je préférerais le jouer avec les
banques etc et noir
c'est moi mais si j'avais les blancs je
jugerai pas que je reviendrai bon
moi je veux dire eh oui il est vraiment
très con avec les noirs il la paie pas
voulu citer ses sources
mais j'ai déjà un pion de plus ça après
tout ce coût sera le champion du monde
débute vraiment bien je ne sais pas
comment je ne bat pas un tel le 8 à 0
mathieu de luxe a déjà été vue par
correspondance 3d vite
et moi je veux bien croire à son dos car
c'est un jeu très vite non mais c'est
sûr que c'est ultra analysé que et qui a
rien pour les blancs c'est sûr en fait
non mais après ça peut se gagner juste
parce que
peut-être les noms
car c'est ni ils maîtrisent pas mal
genre position avec un dynamisme d'une
finale et surtout
des mois pour étudier le truc quoi
quid du choix de dépôt de l'espagnol fab
ah ouais mais bon on va en reparler un
de ce choix ça avait été annoncée par
m6 vie elle dit qu'il fallait pas
rentrer dedans dans cette espagnole
mais bon tout le monde lui dit ne rentre
pas dans l'espagnol ian et jessie fin
il va dedans les poings liés
6 et poings liés il est rentré dans la
gueule du loup non mais c'était sûr en
fait qu'il allait se prendre préparation
préparant l'espagnol failli gâcher ils
cachent des blancs
pour rien en fait ces terribles
bail mais bon
enfin on sent peut-être conclusions quoi
je sais pas en fait des fautes car une
première conclusion de la fab avant de
la porter à d'exclusion 15 minutes de
jeu pour hier conclusion dépôt fait de
la merde non mais c'est vrai il va
perdre demain avec les blancs le match
est déjà terminé et regarde issue
regarde on va mettre un gros plans
dessus issue regardez le ici à grosses
gouttes
regarde bras ça regarde la sueur
questionne mais il se questionne il
s'est hissé qu'il fallait jouer des cas
d'ici j'ai vu nostra planus et je me
suis inventé une life il l'a vu nostra
gladius il ya deux journées peau il a
regardé et il a voulu en faire qu'à sa
tête
ah bah oui mais bon
mes cousins petite finale et on va voir
non mais avoue que c'est une grave
erreur de sa part
mais je sais pas s'ils gagnent on prend
pas dire non mais tu sens qu'il va pas
gagner
bon moi j'ai un nul mais de façon avant
la partie nulle toute façon été un truc
problème
mais bon
ça sentait tellement qu'ils devaient pas
rentrer dans ce cas ils ont remis une
bonne chic et où ils font n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi on voit pas trop y
toucher parce qu'après c'est dur de
revenir on va attendre qu'ils remettent
à
non mais là il est sur le terrain de
magnus
très clairement magnus l'a mené sur son
terrain il s'est levé les hyper confiant
il assure analysé le truc il a encore
dans les variantes
il a encore dans les variantes par
correspondance
mais c'est évident aux femmes l'accès
c'est magnus qui a remporté cette
première petite escarmouche
regarde il est déprimé ça se voit
détecte non mais regarde non mais
franchement
fab
ça se voit qu'il est dingue c'est pas
moi non mais c'est clair son petit
chignon tout ça va
regarde non mais tu vas pas me dire
qu'il ait pas d'acte femme tu peux pas
il a vraiment l'air d'aig
il sait qu'il s'est fait piéger
il s'est fait kayak avec cinq coups
c'est ça il s'est fait cai admont fab
four dans son île c'est qu'il ya deux
heures tranquilles qua
non mais là clairement il est des cas
là clairement il est avec mon fab non
mais je sais pas le mans qu'il a dû
analyser cette position battu les iles
féroé fin tempo
on track baby tu sais même pas de
nouveauté et vu que c'était jeu par
correspondance ont ils ajouté il change
la dame
il va aussi de solidifier son truc
bon justice et que l'autre avait la
bonne ligne ou chance à rien et que je
le vois pas se faire n'importe quoi
donc j'ai quoi la
prime a glissé essayé de le surprendre
avec karelia 5 il doit être vert devoir
est froid et faim tempo
crois tu vois que tu y penses linverse
ils pensent que c'est magnus qui était
gay battant on va regarder la cam 1
qu'il ait des gains
au cours de marches fait le concours de
marche là non c'est parce qu'ils ont
joué par contre bayer prise
il n'y a toujours pas les coûts en fait
non mais faut qu'on mette un homme se
givrent
ok comme vous préviens
ah bah comme prévu
donc en gros avec les noirs j'imagine ce
qu'elle arrive à avoir un avenir sur b4
à une petite pression sur ces deux tu
prends jamais trop de ces trois pour
l'enlever et il va rester là on fait
planter là il va te faire ces cinq qu'il
va mettre les tours au milieu va rien
faire de spécial et quémeneur jarrier
pas de gros danger pour les blancs
j'imagine mais dur d'imaginer exactement
comment
percer sa ensuite
c'est pas évident
même si je prendrai les blancs oui il
faut aussi comme ça je regardais mais
bon
si j'ai dit je m'étais pris cette
position après page se réveille avec les
blancs
si tu mets juste la position et que j'ai
pas que mike a préparé ça je suis très
confiant mais je me sens pas mal
actuellement même si la juge di bombe
peut être beaucoup mieux
s'est tous
les blancs
background oui mais ils ont besoin que
de deux coups pour le fixer
et il y à peine attaques de match ou un
truc comme l'instant ça va aller
ted foot et
2m pour des 4 ko mais comme tu disais si
les noir jaune un jour après jour un
jour avec ses 5 bon admettons tout de
suite c'est juste pour montrer la
structure c'est pas clair que cette
structure soit si bien pour les blancs
en réalité parce qu'il ya une
possibilité de créer un pion à passer et
qui a du jeu sur la colonne c'est aussi
pour les noirs et ab de un peu faible
pouvoir y arrive si les souches quoi et
je sais ça touche autre chose j'sais pas
je pense qu il faut le prendre en photo
donc il se peut que les noix réussissent
à installer à terme un cavalier en
bekkat indélogeable ses sympathisants
ligne que tu regardais tout à l'heure
quand on est tous les deux c'est 5,5 pc
3d mais quatre tours à seurre s'avère
juste logique
après je sais pas ce que font de yolaine
de plus pour les noirs je crois qu'il
faut rien faire
ok karlsson va bien connaître les plombs
à ce qu'il faut faire mais je dis tu
m'appeler tour au centre je pensé
changer les pièces mineurs c'est pas un
problème d épicerie relayé tour
à 2,60 peut pas prendre de la tour sky
prend c'est d'eux
dont le cavalier prend pour un peu
couvrir et tour au centre
et pousse
je sais pas trop comment on va avancer
avec les blancs
médaillon plus enfin je veux dire je
suis d'accord que c'est si énorme
connerie que tu arrives à consolider
ressortir la tête un peu de de l'eau
c'est un ton plus calme
on va voir on va voir comment ça évolue
fab
en tout cas
préparation de nouveaux intéressante 1
comme souvent en championnat du monde
fab les joueurs arrivent avec des idées
de nouvelles bon là ça a été déjà joué
par correspondance mais en pratique du
haut niveau on n'avait jamais vu cette
idée est donc ils viennent avec de
nouvelles idées qu'ils ont étudiés
ardemment chez eux à la maison et il
invente un tout simplement des nouvelles
manières de jouer et ce coup cavaliers à
je vais leur montrer après après h3 donc
ce coup cavaliers à 5,5 ou qu'on reverra
probablement très bientôt dans les toits
de haut niveau voire même dans les
semaines à venir
j'ai passé les tours à de hauts niveaux
en ce moment de 2 au niveau de deux
joueurs qui sont on va dire à 2500 plus
mais tu peux voir ce coup là dès demain
dans un monde en d3
à même dans le match peut être
si l'on peut trouver une idée pour un
petit avantage un truc désagréable il
peut revenir après pas sûr qu'arsène
répétera du coup
est ce que tu penses toi et que c'est
une idée pour une partie ou signer pour
revient avec l'espagnol et rejoue h3 il
va s'entêter magnus dans ce cas valais
as un cubi race le résultat de cette
partie est peut-être déterminant bah
on va le prendre comme j'ai jamais
analysé je peux pas dire à quel point le
coup l'effort ou pas
visuellement si tu es obligé de rentrer
là dedans qui me dit bon bah pourquoi
pas pour les
brèches cherche h3 foulée sept dessins
que ça va pas trop mal pour les noirs
aussi donc je sais pas trop où ali des
données peau de son équipe sur age 3 je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs manières pour
les noirs de répondre
en tout cas ce qu'il y avait à 5 et
objectivement fort et pourrait revenir
dessus sans problème
en tout cas la magnus c'est clair qui
connaît encore il à paris la magnus n'a
pas encore joué un seul coup dans le
même par lui-même de ce championnat du
monde il connaît les plombs il connaît
les idées et il a l'air d'être très bien
préparés sur cette ligne comme s'il
avait lu dans les pensées de yann c'est
comme s'ils avaient vraiment réviser sa
il ya quelques jours même même
simplement quelques heures fabien
ne pas trop pousser quand même
hein
penser la ronde un du match contre
carroll un way carlson est venu avec un
une conception nouvelle contre la
rochelle limoges
est 6e s'était pas trop prévu reçoit
limoux et il vient avec et l'ami le mur
de pierres noires oui je sais j'ai 5 et
d'amd 6 et il part en grand roque et oui
on n'a pas l'habitude de voir ce à quoi
et caruana je ne sais pas s'il a eu
l'occasion de sécher la pression pamela
ici de jouer brême est le cadrage 5
machin il fait ratatiner quoi alors il a
sauvé nul c'est plutôt maxime est plutôt
magnus j'ai raté le gain que fabiano qui
a sauvé murray mais t'as pas envie d'un
scénario pareil et magnus völler très à
l'aise dans la position enfin en tout
cas avec les blancs je prendrai pas de
risques place de dépôt des tu veux dire
qu'il peut se faire saumonade n'a pu
faire gaffe plan à long terme machin tu
bouges pas trop lui l'améliorer
d'améliorer une idée
en tout cas que ces trois semble logique
alors je vois qu'on parle de ces quatre
dans le chat est toute façon ce sera
pédagogique
n'en voulait pas non pourquoi en fait
vous faites des faiblesses partout et
kas faible en d4 donc à ce faible c'est
qu'on nous ait plus de plus en cours
contre la case donc accueillant là
dessus un fou une tour quelqu'un et vous
créez un pion arriérés en d3 qui n'a
plus de pions il ya plus pioncer de son
patron le défendre et voilà et donc il
ya des problèmes partout alors je vais
pas vous dire que ça perd tout de suite
ça se trouve c'est un coup jouable ici
pour une sait quelle raison mais
optiquement ça donne vraiment pas envie
on sait qu'on regarde pas mais je sais
qu'il n'ya pas le joueur amateur pendant
l'écossaise ils vont iclic et vont faire
ces cinq attaques a demandé 4 way est en
fait c'est plutôt un très mauvais
réflexe mais écoutez si là ça marche
quand je vous dis pour je ne sais quelle
raison bah ma foi pourquoi pas mais je
dois juste ça très affaiblissant mais
des fois l'échec qu'on classe et concret
c'est tout ce qu'on aimerait vraiment
ici avec les blancs c'est changer les
pièces que je me rends rouge si on
réussissait à échanger quelques pièces
mineurs on pourrait ensuite imaginé
échanger des tours sur la colonne et le
long de la colonne et si on restait
simplement avec cavaliers contre fout là
on pourrait commencer à monter le roi et
peut-être même avancé le pire en c4
ouais bon soit ça soit tu joues les deux
fous oui
mais en gros on veut échanger des pièces
mineurs ici avec les blancs on a besoin
d'eux qu'ils aient moins de trafic au
centre pour réussir à mouvoir notre
notre structure de pions je peux montrer
allez vas-y on va s'embêter une seconde
on va vous savez quoi on va les changer
les pièces
lui je vais le filet sonore sait on en
attend je veux fier de pouvoir et je
vais changer les fous sont éclatés sur
tokyo 5 atteint structure de pions voilà
maintenant on va échanger les tourelles
enquête qu'on arrive à dans une position
comme celle là ça se serait probablement
assez facile à gagner pour les blancs
parce que maintenant on pourrait
facilement avancer la majorité genre
même dans la situation qu'on avait
auparavant où on se retrouve avec une
faiblesse dont on pourrait facilement
jouer des cats parce que mal et noir
peuvent pas contrôler cette case et on
va réussir à avancer à ce qu'un pion pas
assez c est probablement à gagner là la
partie donc en supprimant des pièces sur
l'échiquier ont réussi beaucoup plus
facilement à faire mouvoir notre
structure de pions
il ya peut être trop d'accord quoi le
problème c'est comme le montre et fable
c'est que le cavaly va venir en b 4 on
va remontrer un cavalier ces trois
cavaliers b4 il va immobiliser une tour
à la défense du pion c2 et les noirs
vont juste se replacer au centre et
finalement ça va être très difficile
pour les blancs de s'organiser et fort
et peut-être réussir à échanger des
tours à remettre le cavalier e 1 le roi
en d1 tu vois genre un truc comme ça
ça va dire ce qu'on va pas y arriver
mais si on réussissait à faire genre
3e de roide et un cavalier f 3
1 mais peut-être qu'ils savent
mais après je sais pas s'il est mort tu
dois je tourne vite de vingt choristes à
rennes pour voir mais ça se trouve tu
fais 6 pour chasser le cavalier ou tu la
tombe des 8 ou
je ne sais pas pour ça avec lens et nice
est par contre
à la karl naegler il a l'air d'être très
au courant des des idées noires ça qui
fait peur pour les peaux il s'est fait
piéger en au petit jeu des préparations
la halle clairement
on demande signer peau est sorti de sa
prépa ben là c'est quasiment sûr parce
qu'il est a déjà une vingtaine de
minutes de réflexion
son langage corporel n'a pas l'air
d'être très positif
magnus il a l'air bien dans sa partie
joue tout tempo il connaît
ça respire pas la sérénité
côté russe fab
non mais par contre comme
disait je crois que si tu sers jack les
blancs c'est moins risqué que cardinal
autrefois qua non non si serre le jeu il
va faire du centre au problème et je
pense
qu'ils imaginent que même toi au mois
contre carl scène ici on serait pas très
inquiet non ouais après c'est bien ça
saoule mais mais
mais en soit je me dirai pas la position
est tellement dangereuse que carlson pas
me battre très facilement mais on en rit
arsenal de lui de l'autre côté
ça vraiment l'air bien
magnus a vraiment l'air bien il a l'air
concentré la guerre dans son match
non mais
bénéfique et ses
310 sera moins bien contre ali reza on
verra un pour le moment il a de très
bons scores magnus contre ali reza et
gagne quasiment à chaque fois ouais puis
bon je viens au japon combinées les
candidats si c'est en grosse forme il a
fait deux énormes tournant a récemment
fait beau ce qu'il a fait mais c'est pas
pour autant que dès 2015 avec les
champions du monde regarde il a l'air
tellement regarde comme il est
tranquille dans la magnus est en train
de faire une démonstration dans cette
première partie fab il va falloir que
les pauvres mettre vite les pendules à
l'heure un côté côté préparation parce
que s'il obtient rien comme ça avec les
blancs et qui se bat à souffrir avec les
noirs demain le match pourrait être très
très long pour pour le joueur russe
après bon
on sait pas mais si tu commences à rien
rien à voir avec les blancs être mal
avec les noirs ça peut vite devenir
pénible
non mais je pense qu'il doit quand même
aujourd'hui pas trop ferman s'il arrive
à concilier décide un peu embêté
ça peut faire mal au moral social
carlson finalement il l'a fini par le
perdre
ils sont tous rompus sur l'autre il
avance merci de mardeuil sur nos cinq
fois que je sais pas faut attendre la
fin de partie
car on nous demande ce sera un match par
jour sur deux semaines alors pas tout à
fait un c c'est quand même une
compétition qui est très très éprouvante
physiquement et pour les organismes ya
eu la cérémonie d'ouverture le 24
novembre donc il ya déjà une première
journée de repos le 25 pour bien
récupérer
et donc là tous les trois jours donc ça
va jouer pendant trois jours puis ça
jouera deux jours enfin les jours de
repos sont pas vraiment symétrique tu
sais pas trop comment ça se repose mais
il va évidemment y avoir je crois six
jours de repos pendant pendant le match
faut bien ce à quoi
peut-être même set quand même histoire
de vraiment vraiment récupéré 22 2010 me
sens bien sur la chaîne me sentais bien
sur mais bon j'aimerais mieux après
chaque partagent une partie un jour de
repos voilà
à avoir deux tu peux te donner un temps
mort en plus au milieu du match au
milieu du match pape je pas il pourrait
y avoir un moment donné c'est vrai un
break peut-être même d'une semaine
entre les deux histoires de bien séparer
la première moitié la deuxième moitié du
match
un coup journée de repos ce qu'ils
veulent
là c'est combien de partis par jour
alors c'est une partie parcours
mais là ça va aujourd'hui et demain il y
en a trois de suite lundi repos après ça
reprend
mardi mercredi je crois que c'est leur
jeu di rupo a pu approcher plus
sans donc le 29 séropos le 2 décembre
c'est repos le 6 décembre sao paulo le 9
décembre cerveau
et après il ya peut-être 12 et 14 un
truc comme ça après ça se repose
rapidement quoi
sur la fin il ya beaucoup de repos
à l'aube à ces magnifiques 1
c'est magnifique fab
notre petite poche depuis 20 ou au que
oui oh que oui
au meilleur des moments
bon bah c'est beau un petit page de pub
qui part
ça fait du bien aux autres gammes sa
voix dans les images
c'est à dire heureusement même sans les
images ça aurait été dur allez un petit
3 minutes
pour poser les premières bases de ce
match
karlsson il a vraiment l'air d'être
facile on peut remettre un peu la cam
sur les peaux qui réfléchit on a un
petit peu fait le tour de la position
des enjeux fab n'est peau et c'est
simplement fait piéger par la
préparation adverse alors après
je suis étonné quand même parce que vlad
m'avait dit qu'il avait des informations
qui venait de l'équipe donné peu qu'ils
allaient prendre des risques dans les
ouvertures des lap dès le premier match
c'est de mettre magnus sous pression
parce qu'il pensait vraiment que c'était
en début de match que magnus pouvait
être friable et je suis vraiment très
étonné par ce choix d'ouverture c'est
aussi pour ça que que je suis aussi déçu
parce qu'on nous on nous a promis le feu
côté russe et finalement c'est même pas
un pistolet à eau sur la glace
bon après je veux pas dire qu'ils
voulaient pas prendre jusqu'à je crois
peut-être qu'il s'attendait à juste fou
bessette avec des 5 et qu'il avait une
idée là dessus
l'idée que peut-être l'équipe de carlson
également et qui se sent dix bombes
esquiver la balle de match à 5 je sais
pas tu
ne sais pas il n'a pas fait innocemment
là je crois non plus
hélas avons
trouvé il va arriver la guinée quand
même cette partie moi je dis bon ok on
est d'accord sur le fait se doit les
pour les noirs il ya des compensations
que cette trailer d'annoncé pour les
blancs coin après
qu un époux est sérieux il faut pas
tempo oui on a pu s'inquiéter de sa
avant le début de ce match il prend son
temps et calculé réfléchi
je cherchais un set up en fait tu vois
c'est d'être en difficulté qui comprend
très bien ok le matelot qui en met 4 les
torts au centre f 6 3 7 5 en place
qu'est ce que je fais est donc là il
peut va pas jouer un coup à pas cliquer
au hasard il va cliquer au hasard mais
on est en bien réfléchi ce que tu peux
pas imaginer que ce cas va lire
reviennent vers vers 3 la peau d'autres
pour couvrir ces deux sera tenu au
greffe 3 où le maître est naturellement
attention parce que tu aurais peut-être
te prendre un petit afficheur tout ça
pour quoi
enfin tirer depuis le début de bastien a
pas écoutés on peut repasser la partie
rapidement on va parler expliqué ils
n'ont pu espagnol voilà c'est l'espagnol
carles scène à jouer un coup très rare
je dirais qu'en
bientôt
du très classique
est hélas bien saine paraît que son
cavalier les scorpions centrale en
prison qu'il ne sacrifie
pas pour gagner le fou de cases blanches
thé blanc et donc à voir la paire de fou
donc là les joueurs récitent leurs
variantes une petite bref un temps
mettez des coûts subtil pour art
explique et non dans le récap ce soir
sur youtube et
on tombe la voilà donc on en est là les
dames ont été échangées donc on est
dehors d'une sorte de finale les blancs
un pion de plus mais en échange qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire que non la peur de
fou une meilleure activité
est ce facile de voir comment les blancs
peuvent essayer de profiter de ce pion
pas bien mais tu as bien résumé fab et
dépôts qui est bloqué sur cette position
entre guillemets depuis maintenant un
peu plus de 22 20 minutes à presque 25
minutes qui bloque sur cette finale
apparemment il sait pas comment comment
la prendre à bras le corps j'ai envie de
dire un magnus carlsen lui assez
confiant mais il commence déjà à
réfléchir en voici maintenant depuis
plus d'une dizaine de minutes on sent
qu'il a envie de rentrer dans cette
partie et dans ce match de championnat
du monde le le norvégien le champion du
monde le viking le king le roi
c'est lui qui est maintenant leader au
classement elo depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années
l'ours non ça ça va être tout l'ours
c'est pas du tout dans le champ lexical
norvégien
un jeune en bourse c'est plutôt dépôts
non le roi de la nuit quoi le roi de la
nuit
l'homme de la glace le saumon 1 le
second
en tout cas
il est une nouvelle fois très bien
préparés pour ce match de championnat du
monde son équipe a réalisé un magnifique
travail ils ont réussi à pressentir ce
que je choisirais dépôt
jean est là où d'autres venus me
chercher de
10 du coût de près par des petites
surprises on
demande à voir il domine déjà c'est sûr
là à battre c'est clair maintenant
maintenant on est vraiment sur la phase
d'ouverture était dominé par carlos elle
se veut pas dire qu'il gagnera la partie
non mais il a un adversaire na ou oui le
maire est en tout cas il était presque
ça et sur ce terrain là
moi je suis vraiment inquiet pour pour
la stratégie de match globale donnée
paume un an bien tant pis
on s'en fout complètement c'est pas
notre live mais
honnêtement tu te fais prendre comme sa
partie un haut blanc quand on voit une
espagnole
puis tu te fais prendre très tôt un
coup ci
c'est vraiment inquiétant parce que tu
as vraiment même pas touché le début de
la prépa devers st
j'étais juste prix en mai tu doutes en
fait que ça tourne autour de
deux marshals
n'en ferai pas oui en fait je suis rincé
3c lemarchal ouais c'est sûr à quatre
c'est peut-être une autre comme combat
qui ou quoi mais qui peut garder des
cinq qui paraît hélas il te refais un
truc à la marche alors en fait il veut
te filer un pion à chaque partie jouée
l'activité ouais ça au moins tu le
comprends c'est tout mais de comprendre
avant de ces lieux retard oui mais là tu
es sûr mais c'est la seule info que tu
as chopper
et j'ai envie de te dire c'est pas si
lourd ce que les partis dont on n'a pas
beaucoup avec les blancs ça n'a que sept
donc si la prochaine comme disait vlad
je veux c'est un papa sur cette
interview là mais j'avais déjà parlé
avec lui il m'avait dit faut essayer
d'ouvrir la carte en une deux parties
max site en faut trois à quatre pour
commencer à toucher un peu vraiment le
fond de la prépa et quitterait ce que
partie 5,6 est
peu changée os oui il commence à sentir
c'est ça c'est rod non mais oh pierre si
tu sembles tétreault dominé va enterrer
un art théorique
anglaise et 3g 3g pas quoi
non mais c'était pas le bruit média par
lasser c'est quand même un gros à
monsieur place henri lafay cavaliers f3
donc il est hors québec quatre tours
c'est un probablement de mettre un câlin
à trois jeux pas pourquoi ça peut être
aussi une idée regardez les tours sur
dont 4 on va regarder donc sbk tour euh
c'est un ce serait une option et
cavaliers à 300 peut-être plus
intéressant mais comme tu le disais
enfin on va ré expliquer ça parce que
c'est intéressant fou prend b4 c'est pas
vraiment un coup
bas salaires dangereux même pour les
blancs cette fois c'est perdre comme ça
parce que les normes voir la pression de
ma colonne c'est donc un pur annoncé de
touchable tu as le pion à qui peut être
passé notamment si les tours s'échange
ou coin il va qu'on sait à faire son
petit bonhomme de chemin à 5 à 4 à 3 et
compagnie et à des gens qui le
soutiennent et la paire de flou souvent
moyen de pièces sur l'échiquier puis
elle parle cet échange des tours est
vraiment là donc il faut prendre les 4
on va mettre comme coup qu'on n'a pas
envie de faire si on obligeait on obligé
mais si on peut s'abstenir on va
préférer donc je ferai pas donc après ce
qu'il veut faire tour c1 il se dit c'est
mieux de mettre cette tour la gare de la
tour sur la colonna parce que c'est une
colonne ouvert un semi ouverte et je
sais pas ce qu'il a pensé mais pourquoi
pas ou cavalia 3
pour défendre défendre ses devrait et tu
te dis bah moi je vais doubler mes tours
sur la colonne heures
et puis mon kf3 il pourra refaire sa vie
ailleurs
je sais pas j'ai pas exactement quel
plan mais tu peux te pensé à faire du
fou ces trois fois aux cinq ans a
échangé des pièces et petit à petit on
est la stratégie qu'on avait avant ce
tube l'inde un peu des trois après de
france et 3 verra le cavalier de mes 4
mai pour avoir défendu de chars bien des
trois en coin et te dire voilà après je
mets la marche avant donc bon écoute
pourquoi pas ça peut être une option au
nom si vous êtes rejoint pour tuer
structure c'est peut-être jouable en
fait je prendrais ça pour une bonne
nouvelle avec les blancs parce qu'en
fait je m'en fous de ses pions doublé
ils sont pas vraiment attaquable n'était
pas ma chum à montréal où j'avais la
majorité donc au moins je dirais qu'il
ya plus de paires de fou en face et
donc je trouve ça pour une bonne
nouvelle non plus à dans la case ou
quatre mètres une tour et ramener
l'autre je sais pas à quel point c'est
mieux je vois la turbine a dit me qu'on
est même plutôt égal mais mais moi je
connais ça comme étant bonne nouvelle
pour les blancs assez d'accord avec toi
mais
tu sais en tout cas que tu auras plus de
pression du tout à subir et que vraiment
pire ça fera nul parce que je savais
comme tu le dis là normalement tu vas
pas la perdre mais c'est vrai que ce
qu'elle est on des quatre c'est un faux
frais j'ai envie de te dire j'ai du mal
à voir aussi comment les noirs avancent
un rebond après carlos n
est qu il est très bon on se protège des
trucs et peut être que lui est capable
un jeu qu'on va dire je serais surpris
mais
alors j'ai pas la turbine atteint pour
la turbine à tous et sans doute jusqu'à
demain à l'intérieur on a une toute
petite turbine à toi qui nous sert pas
forcément avoir des évaluations propre
et fiable ça donne juste une idée pour
vérifier s'il ya une gaffe voilà
je pourrais la chercher si on fait une
petite pause un moment lorsqu'il raconte
ah ben est-ce qu on se mettrait pas sur
un plan large de calmes on voit que les
pauses s'est levé on
voit que l'epo s'est levé en fin et qui
fait réfléchir pour la première fois de
ce match magnus carlsen sérieusement
parce que lecavalier a cinq qui le
connaissaient un quand il envoyer magnus
la cavalière 3 c'est peut-être le
premier coup en terre inconnue de deux
magnus d'être le premier coup de ce
championnat du monde en réalité pour
pour le joueur norvégien
[Musique]
on va essayer de réchauffer une came
c'est pas la bonne on va mettre
peut-être celle là qu'il ya un petit peu
sympa c'est à ça donne une impression de
points de vue avec les blancs
car la scène très concentré
il est immobile bas comme un caruana
caruana il bouge beaucoup ils changent
fréquemment de position de sa réflexion
car le sanwi c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas
encore de la veste mi s'immobilise dans
une position il réfléchit il calcule ce
mot me fit
donc s'il y avait les p4 ensemble
sur le coup logique car on l'a dit info
pro b 4 et pas vraiment jouable mais il
a raison d'un fléchissement en fait même
s'il quasi sûr phoques et emeka tous en
fait
le seul défaut de rennes grosse ferait
pas c'est que en fait tu joues pas
tu vois si à un moment où tu as en toi
quand même devoir jouer un coup l'autre
va sortir où ça va s'arrêter et tu es un
peu âpre et parfois tu prennes mauvaise
décision pour le projet coûte t à jouer
et donc la même s'il quasi sûr jeu qui
avait quatre c'est peut-être pas mal de
ses dix minutes injuste jean louis
barrault à ok pour justement être prêt à
prendre de bonnes décisions le jour où
ça arrive c'est souvent une très très
bonne idée lorsqu'on a une grosse ferait
pas de se mettre à réfléchir
au premier coup on comment dire ça fait
là il a la chance d'avoir un coût qu'il
est quasiment sûr de jouer ces cahiers
b4 mais qui est peut-être pas dans sa
prépa et donc il est quasiment sûr de
pas se tromper ça donc c'est bien c'est
bien et en plus ça lui permet du coup
pour le coup suivant qui devra vraiment
joué de s'être de cette chauffer donc
c'est vraiment l'histoire c'est un tour
de chauffe c'est comme en formule 1 un
tour de chauffe pour voir les pneus bien
jouer bonne température c'est ça ouais
pour avoir les pnas bonne température
est un petit peu sauf les roues de la
chaise
magnifique
s'inquiète un peu d'eau pour un petit
volet pineau mouillé
est-ce que c'est rosen qui prend des
photos derrière à c'est possible parce
que maintenant il est un photographe
officiel rapport évidemment magnifique
cette nouvelle n'y a pas trop de
photographe en fait
c'est possible que ce soit lui je suis
pas sûr
ouais ben écoute j'ai du mal à savoir
savoir s'il pourrait jouer d'autres
qu'on dit cavaliers f4 dans le chat pour
menacer cavaliers pros h3 meybon fo
prend f4 prise à 4 et carré lisse et 3
ça je pense c'est plutôt dans l'intérêt
des blancs même si on s'est séparés des
deux fous au moins ont réussi à se
développer on pourra essayer peut-être
de valoriser ce pion de plus déjà il ya
plus de pression dans ces deux bon ok
premier truc ça fait plaisir
donc il ya plus qu il ya un b 4 qui
devait mobiliser une tout je ne sais
quoi et blanc allaient faire tout ça tu
ne t'attends prochain coup autour d'eux
et d'où les victoires c'est probablement
jouable pour les noirs mais comme je
disais je suis pas convaincu mais je
crois quand même ressenti que moi qu'on
doive côté nord à changer une pièce
caisse mineurs ouais je pense qu'on doit
garder les trois pièces mineurs et comme
tu le disais ce cas et b4 jeu vraiment
insister dessus mais fou prend b4y
signer échange les pièces mais moins
fort parce que ça ouvre la colonne c'est
comme on l'a montré et ça donne
potentiellement un pion passé a je pense
qu'on a fait le tour de la position en
fait fabre on a vraiment expliquer les
enjeux après il ya autant de manières de
jouer cette position que deux joueurs à
la presse et aux fermes taf de réfléchir
[Musique]
si les noirs prennent la colonne ouverte
ouais mais c'est très bien c'est pas m
pas mauvais coups bas du coup ça peut
retomber carrément dans la vente qu'on
avait tout à l'heure qui avait laissé 3
proposait les changes cavaliers b4 pour
taper ses deux tours à ses seins
peut-être vous pouvez faire du couteau
fonds de huit italiens deux morts deux
tours c'est une version qui aimait
4 peut-être
il ya des petites subtilités dans la
position on peut avoir un plan comme
camaïeu de ces trois peut-être le
cavaliere est assez bien placé en
réalité bizarrement est loin il n'est
pas fiable et il défend un peu tous un
peu le pirlo de la position complètement
la cua
mais à vrai dire si tu veux faire nul
avec les blondes a tout le temps
cavaliers aux 4 après de change tout
échange du faux
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas y'a pas
grand risque pour les blancs le seul
truc qui est dommage c'est peut-être
qu'ils gaspillent un blanc mais allez va
savoir il va falloir aussi que carl
scène joue une bonne partie d'échec
parce qu'on a dit que c'était un diesel
magnus dans cette première partie peut
jouer un petit peu en dessous de son
niveau habituel
il a sorti la prépa mais bon au final
maintenant il faut quand même jouer une
partie du jeu d'échecs et oui nous
habitue pas à faire des gaffes un magnus
mais dans ces matches du championnat du
monde avec la pression avec ce pion de
moins et encore beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent se passer quand même aujourd'hui
mais rien n'est fait hier sa prépa
intéressante et es5 ça va être un ti
punch et dessus parce que 5 ou méconnus
et qu'elle est intéressant
mais toujours est il que maintenant ils
me parties à jouer et les bleus en
option de plus sa part d'être trop
dramatique pour les normes
mais avoir une vie dans le chat le prix
d'un coup
l'expression de leur tasse 1 le prix
d'un coup au ventre le prix de secouer
patrouille non là ça va
mais à tout moment il peut y avoir un
coût très cher très cher et
il se passe
fab on va pas se mentir ces matches de
championnat du monde c'est bien parce
qu'il ya la tension du match genre de
stress qui en train d'être évacués par
les joueurs mais à vrai dire la première
partie du match carlson caruana vous
avez vraiment mis tout de suite dans le
bain avec un rock opposé un gros jeu
date at un combat vraiment ardant dans
un milieu de partie d'une rosso limo
sortie d'une sicilienne
là c'est vrai qu'on a quand même plus
une petite finale est
l'enjeu a peut-être dépassé le jeu pour
cette première partie on va voir mais
oui c'est vrai que c'est pas une partie
une position où il ya des grandes
variantes à calculer c'est plus
stratégique et
ça va évoluer toute façon exactement
mais quand on s'attend à québec
attraperait pour un bouquet d'autres
options autour du tout vous l'avez dit
même qualif 4 pourquoi pas même si on le
stim pas trop mais pourquoi pas et puis
je sais pas qui a et b 4 il peut aussi
voir jet tours c'est notre cas la 3d
pourrait n'arriver qu'à ya trois ça
semblait logique mais c'est ainsi
également l option je sais pas moi c'est
mon ressenti j'irai sur calais à 3 mais
voilà
b4 philidor ça j'aime pas du tout fait
des trous faut pas faire de trouver
chaque type éviter en fait cette fille
là depuis la casse et 4 blancs et
voitures situes tu enlèves la case des
quatre pour ton cheval en plus ils vont
y mettre un cavalier dessus il va
rayonner il va trôner en c4
faut jamais faire ça en fait c'est ce
que peut faire le carillon c4 si tu veux
tu as soir sur le trône tu vas t'asseoir
sur mes genoux
il voudra pas liée à la non
au nom pas de b4 c'est sûr
comment se sont passées les précédentes
finales championnats du monde car ça est
il toujours conservé facilement son
titre oh que non oh que non pas très
facile à dire qu il ya des champions
2013 il a rejoué à nantes le match
d'après il a gagné plutôt facilement
mais
on simplement c'est un meilleur joueur
et kannad plutôt vieillissant copains
dans sa tombe plus mais je veux dire il
est en fin de carrière à très haut
niveau après il a quand même faire
encore des tournois ou quoi mais voilà
un an de gens magnifiques années 90 2000
une année 2010
donc là il était trop fort pour son
adversaire après les deux autres matches
qu'il a vu l'a fait nul contre car
yakine important c'est aussi un meilleur
joueur et contre caruana ils ont fait 6
6 à chaque fois et contre carey qui
n'était même mené 1-0 ils perdent il a
gagné il faut des partages donc ça n'a
jamais été des parties de plaisir les
matchs pour karam sanaa c'est pour ça
que dans une première partie d'un match
du championnat du monde même même si ça
se passe plutôt bien pour lui jusqu'à
maintenant attention quand même magnus
alors que je pense qu'on a un problème
de pendule 1 je pense qu'on a un bug sur
sur le timer jazz comme je suis en train
d'y réfléchir pendant que tu parlais
parce qu'on est à cinquante deux minutes
de jeu et qu' ils entrent ils n'ont que
48 enlevés à leur show by a forcément
une erreur on n'a pas une zone pour nul
n'a pas de suspendu le
bon après
ouais ils doivent pas être 21h40 ont dit
ok mais bon
maintenant clairement tu vois c'est ce
que c'est ce que je pressentais ça
pouvait pas mathématiquement gym ne sont
pas bons kevin les chiffres ne sont pas
bons c'est ça des calculs ne sont pas
bons
est ce qu'elle est des gaffes dans
l'histoire à ce niveau de la compétition
jamais jamais
si bien souvent
car sinon il y avait une grosse gaffe un
hymne à la beauté est réciproque on n'a
pas su en profiter dans le passé il y en
ad énormes danse arrive à caen tient une
grosse tension défaut
non clairement dans ce match on pourrait
voir une énorme gaffe un moment donné
qui pourrait même être une perte de
pièces en un ou deux coups oui ça peut
arriver un
nom ça après bons ajustements on espère
que ça arrive parce que c'est censé être
les deux meilleurs joueurs du moment qui
s'affrontent et donc on espère toujours
voir des parties brillante etc etc mais
du temps on était tous en jeu cette
pression sera êtres humains donc
j'essaye de me faire une idée il ya du
monde dans la salle j'ai l'impression
que c'est absolument vide
c'est difficile à voir passer très
sombre mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
c'est pas vide mais presque en tout cas
il n'y a pas de fumigène et d'authie fo
qui sont là sont très calme
je vois pas vraiment alors attends est
ce que je sais pas si ça va marcher
femme je vais
tenter un truc
on nous voit plus on a ça qui est mal
cadré mais on va pouvoir se renvoie la
saône et de la salle ouais ouais c'est
ça a pas l'air d'être plein là pas l'air
d'être très grande et ça a pas l'air
d'être très plein mais c'était quand
même sympa de se faire une petite une
petite idée comme une vue d'ensemble
peut la laisser un petit moment 7
cette caméra fab
ça l'aide et je les gens qui partent en
fait un vêtement non mais c'est vrai je
suis ce que je suis arrivé il ya quatre
gars qui sont passés il ya personne qui
arrive il ya quelqu'un qui sont
forgé une tomate way serait magnifique
qui leur jettent des trucs halak c'est
pour ça qu'ils les vitres en fait je ne
prenais pas baissé pas été les tomates
imaginant 45 riches à la la la la la la
abbas à mettre un peu d'ambiance à
dire est qu'ils regardent un aquarium
basse ça fait un peu l'impression sauf
que ça bouge un petit peu plus côté
poisson
il faut voir en grande calmes ce que ça
donne
[Musique]
1h35 entre 1h26 heure ben oui en grande
camon la voix magnifique caméra aérienne
c'est peut-être la meilleure qu'avant
vrai nom très bien c'est ce que voulait
qu'on garde cet cas mais on se met en
semaine- ou en cadeaux dessus
est ce que vous préférez l'échiquier en
grand elecam en petit éventuellement
ouais franchement c'est cool façon la
position on a fait le tour
battant quand il joue on prend venir on
n'a plus rien à dire en vrai on n'a plus
rien à dire peut-on d'oran où une plume
de way bientôt dans quatre livres on
voit une pub
pour être bien sûr
ce que l'on n'est pas forcément bien sûr
je le mets en petit khalfa ben non alors
on n'est pas encore tout à fait là mais
on va y arriver
c'est un truc un peu technique
ne me lasse très technique
en fait en tout petit en fait
c'est bien mais je viens c'est plus
technique à réaliser que des trente ans
un peu des petites photos d'identité
ouais
bah on est bien comme ça non
on est petit quoi
c'est la première fois que les joueurs
sont séparés public par une baie vitrée
non je crois pas ça fait un petit moment
déjà fischer spassky
puis donc justement maintenant avec les
moyens modernes communication quoi c'est
puis quand même mieux de t'isoler les
joueurs kippen doute
il a pas l'air super serein non plus qui
et magnus bien c'est vrai que
il ya de la tension pas d'armes mais
j'ai quand même tout le moins quoi
j'avais pas fait gaffe
non mais ça va
salon nous fait remarquer l'échiquier
n'ai pas droit c'est vrai regarde elle
un peu vrai ils ont un petit peu ne
pouvait demeurer un petit coup de coude
donné
[Musique]
il ya eu un petit coup de petit goût de
quelque chose et peut-être pas de coup
de fabien terrible
qui fléchit
[Rires]
ce serait magnifique en partant quoi
gilles décalque yankee
magnifique
2h30 il y avait des infos
contradictoires pas ce que vont très dur
de courant des décalages horaires mais
13h30 tous les jours sera 13h30
après ce qui est beau c'est qu'il ya eu
il ya eu trois informations et 12h30
13h30 et 14h30 bon on appris au mieux
nos vies a pris au milieu
ça marche souvent bien
quand tu demandes à une foule d'estimé
quantifie un truc dont la moyenne est
bien taillé les optimistes les
pessimistes
gens qui jugent bien à peu près la
moyenne assez proche de la réalité
moi j'avais 15h30 dans le concret
est-ce que manu tu cherches un nul l'âme
non ils cherchent un coup bêtement pas
là c'est vraiment ont joué un coup en
fait ce qu'il essaye de faire
bon il va jouer un coup mais qui va lui
permettre de mettre son plan aussi
ensuite
je sais pas s'il adore lequel est embêté
4 priori la traîne jazz ça il va jouer
la halle et envoie le cheval là il va
jouer normalement ça être cavale et b4
mais bien évidemment magnus n'a pas
réfléchi kokou qui va jouer actuellement
il a aussi réfléchi à la suite fab pour
tous aux gens ce bien dont il veut le
faire
dd
on a un petit
un petit problème sur sur le hac donc on
va laisser la position en grand pour le
moment fabre jusqu'à ce que ça jusqu'à
ce que ça vienne à venir c'est un coût
qui change pas grand chose pour le
moment puisqu'il garde toutes ses
options
on voit les joueurs on voit bien là la
feuille de partie
la très colorée une fois
c'est vrai que les gens demandent
souvent qu'est ce que les joueurs note
sur la feuille on leur dit les coups on
leur répond bien évidemment ce qu'il
note mais c'est vrai que là on a une
vision plus détaillée que d'habitude
et a pas de lettres et de chiffres non
ya pas d coordonnée autour de cet
échiquier après les joueurs
professionnels n'ont pas vraiment besoin
un fab pas trop mais toi tu utilises
quand même un petit peu je sais d'eux
est bien
f si
tu te trompe encore quelques quelques
fausses notes
d'ailleurs si vous voulez bien à prendre
les coordonnées vous pouvez faire le jeu
sur ds comme vision et d'en apprendre le
petit menu à gauche il ya vision et vous
cliquez vous demande au nom des cases
alors là faut pas qu'ils co hasard il
faut bien cliqué de loisirs 6364
beaucoup plus compliqué que les échecs
les échecs mots tu as des pièces tu les
mets un peu au hasard sur des cases là
elle s'appelait non non non là il faut
vraiment tomber sur les bonnes cases 3
c'est difficile paquet très mauvaise je
ne peux le mot-clic
beaucoup trop dur
est-ce que tu dois encore noté les coups
quand il reste ce genre une minute
comment ça se passe alors ça c'est une
très bonne question parce que tu dois le
faire quand hier du rajoutant deux
médailles en position mais comme ici il
n'ya pas de rajoute temps quand il te
restera moins de cinq minutes tu ne sera
plus obligé de noter les coûts
les joueurs font parfois un petit trait
pour voir s'il arrive au 40e
[Musique]
après tu peux notez un peu sale
s'il avoue 30 secondes vois-tu d'hommes
été jusqu'au bout
record sur vision je suis pas une
trentaine sur l'avenue 35 minutes je
crois à la norme et vision du jeu a
réuni 35 trentaine une trentaine
trentaine trentaine de cris
mais souhaite possible de tout en
essayant de bien dépasser 40 quand et
comment est ce qu'ils ont
comment est-ce qu'ils ont choisi les
couleurs c'était un tirage au sort avec
un ballon a explosé
ça m'a exposé le ballon et les confettis
noir dedans c'est ça mais bon on prête
bien sûr est né pour exploser l'autre et
bien les confettis blanche de nos
provisions non en fait provision c'est
juste que des fois je le montre à des
gens justement qui galèrent avec les
coordonnées d'un regard de gaza le fait
de vendre tu feras tout est prêt
pourquoi mettre l'horloge et la prise de
notes dans ce genre de match par la
pendule c'est utile pour limiter dans le
temps parce que sinon allégeant un temps
illimité il pourrait ne jamais s'arrêter
je ne joue pas je ne ris va bien revenir
et la prise de note abbas et en cas de
problème avec les labos transmission de
l'échiquier on voit qu il peut y en
avoir c'est pour avoir une trace écrite
des coups joués après c'est vrai car
entre la caméra et l'échiquier bon tu
veux on pourrait s'en passer mais c'est
par tradition veut être aussi
à moi depuis que je suis petit j'ai
toujours joué des parties noté voilà
la salle qui pourrait ne pas noter mais
en même temps
je sais pas si
[Musique]
une partie longue sans noter en fait
tout evolupharm après oui
juste à l'habitude de faire ce truc
je reconnais que ça sert plus à
grand-chose de gâcher du papier
fait quand même plaisir de gâcher un peu
ce papier oui non c'est vrai
surtout qui en a pas il y en ad'autres
pâtit g derrière pour le mec le père est
revenue pour être bien sûr si jamais et
tu veux récupérer ta partie qui annihile
gagner plus sur les sites
parce que monsieur rose lordon ses
coordonnées sur les mots en français
qu'en anglais alors oui en fait c'est
les mêmes hélas que tu cites c'est que
juste à l'époque il n'avait pas les
coordonnées justement donc il faisait à
autre chose et par exemple dire
cavaliers f3 ils vont te dire le
cavalier du côté du roi sur la colonne
du fou troisième ligne c'était plus
compliqué
c'était une case devant le pion un truc
comme ça
jara fischer pour jouer au hockey à
diviser pic à 4 mais ça c'est encore
plus évoluée un big mac c'est encore
pire donc voilà en fait dont il galérait
et puis un jour ils sont fiables on va
numérotée des trucs comme la bataille
navale quoi un puits puis voilà ça
depuis simple
voilà
mais du coup c'est quel que soit le pays
c'est pareil hein c'est juste si la
montée les coordonnées je crois qu'avant
avant c'était genre cavaliers du côté
roy avance une case vraiment le pire
joueur
n'aime pas qu'on quoi
il paraît qu'à l'époque c'était pas si
c'est un autre pensée
dans la série qu'une fois que le druide
ans que je prends quand même en
mathématiques n'avait pas encore les
apsys et désordonnée non donc du coup
sûr c'est comme la roue
fait avant eux les wagons mais la roue
plus dur quand même oui mais derrière
maintenant que c'est inventé oui oui
c'est qu'on la retrouve sur la
technologie vers la roue
et pas si simple
ce que tu devais faire un truc rond qui
roulait qui se cassent pas donc du coup
la rousse c'est pas si simple du tout là
les coordonnées quand même c'est à 6
mdeur cloud tu te dis normalement tu
dois y penser mais à vrai dire je vais
être un petit peu rendu compte
j'étais un petit peu enseigné pendant
longtemps
ce n'est pas si samedi penser
selon revêtement la roue pour une patron
de
10 les épices et les ordonné ces vieux
ouais ça peut être 300 400 ans mais les
échecs sont à 1200 donc
c'est pas si ce n'était pas si simple de
l'aide de les adapter aux échecs
est ce que les voir se mettre d'accord
sur le choix de l'échiquier alors là je
crois que c'est ce que c'est le filet de
chasse 7 mai qui est un petit peu changé
parce qu'avant il y avait un petit point
blanc et un petit point noir
devant les blancs et les noirs qui n'est
plus présent
donc c'est pas tout à fait le même nom
mais l'échiquier mais la très standard
jardé j'étais très souvent et les pièces
bonjour à ce joli en fait
blessé enfin julien
qui rajoute ponctuation d'air les
coordonnées commencé laquelle il faut
mettre alors ça c'est souvent les
personnes qui analyse qui rajoute une
ponctuation suivant s'ils trouvent les
coûts bon mauvais ça évalue généralement
un coup
exactement
pendant sur leurs feuilles il met pas de
ponctuation justement tu penses qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit d air juste les coûts
noté le temps cette envie
ça pas grand chose noté le temps je
pense c'est plutôt un truc peu quand on
est petit si l'entraîneur demande parce
que c'est pas de savoir où le joueur a
dépensé le temps sur tel coup quoi et
pour lui apporter une meilleure gestion
du temps et voilà surtout un joueur qui
est souvent avec notes et ben c'est pas
mal de voir m affiche à ce coup ci mais
ses comptes aurait pu faire comme ça où
je sais pas faim on va mieux l'aiguillé
quoi
je pense c'est bien imagine comment tu
réussit à vis de pièces d'échecs du deux
pièces du jeu d'échec quand est utilisé
pour les championnats du monde de quoi
imaginer comment ta réussite à vis de
pièces d'échecs comptait utiliser away
seconde fois un ballon de foot de chance
de découvrir c'est la consécration pour
le cavalier f3
en tout cas les
vraiment beaucoup en ce début de match
oui on s'attendait pas forcément à sa
femme mais comme on le disait un le le
prix d'un coup alors ici dans cette
position il n'est pas très élevé mais ce
qui est élevé c'est le fait que c'est un
coup deux matches de championnat du
monde ce qui augmente son prix 1 mais
juste la faute à une option en plus avec
les blancs par rapport à normalement
c'est que tafua 5
à sa gauche quand même pas regardé en
temps normal là tu touches la tour donc
tu fais par un temps tu dis bah
peut-être faire cailler d2 je sais pas
pourquoi cette fan au set-up possible
donc pourquoi pas envisager en fait oui
presse que c'est bien par intel ont pu
faire jusqu'à et c3 peut-être il peut
quand même pas retiré du cavalier à
trois ans
et voilà
on ne sait pas bah ouais non
là clairement il ya beaucoup d'options
qui doivent plus ou moins être
équivalent d'ailleurs
il n'y a pas forcément un coup vraiment
plus fort qu'un autre là c'est une
question de choix
imagine t es foutu ça entraîne depuis 15
ans pour te faire échanger au 5e
vainqueur
bon après ça tu reviens le lendemain
attendre une deuxième chance
si on a le temps de voir deux peut-être
un
le problème du fonds à cinq ans et qui
contrôlera plus à caser f4 après oui non
mais
c'est un vrai défaut
comment se prononcent n'est pas d'être
nepomniachi
[Musique]
onf a battu les arbitres a fuit pas les
notaires c'est lucien litiges pendants
ou que tout le monde trois fois la même
position ou d'autres choses comme ça que
là il à sept-îles de vérifier une fois
que la partie est finie les filles
internautes et n'importe quoi c'est pas
très grave
sassus un peu côté dépôt maintenant ça
réfléchit mais bon comme on le disait un
il a vraiment le temps la pendule il lui
reste 1h15 pour jouer 23 coup et à vrai
dire il aura pas normalement de coûts si
complet avec ça
j'ai envie de te dire c'est l'heure de
mettre une petite pub fab four
sort de bien avancer dans ce match
et ses trois cahiers sera joué bon du
coup ça retombe en quelques cent dans la
position que l'on attendait avec toi il
ya une petite heure de sa non mais je
pense hélas peu après québec 4 c'est
plutôt rien on avait la tour en 1 8 mai
c'est la position qu'on avait vers les
13h45 13h50
oui va penser basse et touré autour des
8 et réalise enfin c'est dur à dire mais
c'était c'est vraiment c'est la position
qui paraissait critique c'est après ce
coup là que ça va vraiment commencer à
jouer mais les joueurs ont dû anticiper
en amont ou même en benoît hamon les
coûts à venir fab
à bas les petites qui partent
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir bah oui en gros t'es
content
hub au québec la place
donc voilà il n'a pas envie d'échanger
c'est logique le cas et b4 bien placé
pénible vise ces deux donc les blancs
vont devoir réagir avec une tour anciens
alors moi j'imagine à toi tu dois être
l'autre aussi
finalement
on va voir demain - logique à mes yeux
mais
les deux coups sont possibles fab
les deux coups sont sont tout à fait
possibles tout à fait jouable
les peaux qui s'est levé il est parti va
revenir rapidement
gens qui ont été publiés fait quand même
plaisir des petites pub il faut partir
comme ça six minutes par heure c'est pas
tant que ça ça fait que 10% du programme
c'est pas énorme montfa ben non c'est
pour être plus tu pense qu'on peut je
vais écrire à temps est-ce que j'ai
créée par angie pour l'une pour lui dire
tu sais quoi dany tu es bien sûr ce que
tu es bien sûr nous en france on a
vraiment l'habitude de la pub je pense
qu'on peut mettre peut-être un petit 15
minutes par heure
je veux dire pour être vraiment bien sûr
pour que le tour
sont finalement en réalité la de décider
de mettre la tour e quand il a joué food
et 2
mais magnus aurait pu forcer torah en
jouant cavalier b4 directement vécu à 3
et cavaliers atteindre quelque chose du
coup ouais
alors comment est-ce qui va continuer
maintenant magnus
toi tu proposes est tout à l'heure un
coup comme fouet fuite éventuellement
même pour cacher le fouet et faire jouer
la tour
le long de la colonne pour copains voilà
je crois que tous les pouvoirs vous en
fait normal vous les fuites pourquoi pas
et si ce pourquoi pas devoir c'est
évident un mach 6 on sait pas pourquoi
tout va
tout est bon
toujours et en fait la question c'est
pas tellement con tu veux que les moeurs
et les blancs que tu fais après comment
tu avances ouais c'est ce qu'ont
expliqué
merci c'est mon devoir bref si tu sais
pas m parce que tu prends des cases ou
cavalières 37.1 d'amener tombant vers le
centre et voilà tu as fait
55 g 4 1 jour 1 pour taper la russie
n'est pas tout quasiment changes chez
les blancs book m6 a très bien fait et
si ce petit à petit poucet a eu droit
tout à fait pas beau
ça se joue ça se joue mon fab voilà tout
ce jour
un pote à tort qu'ils ne montent on peut
expliquer le tour f 2,8 de l'ouverture
il ya assez simple à expliquer on peut
revenir rapidement sur l'ouverture après
le h3 je dirais bon c'était théorique
théorique théorique h3 qui est un genre
d'anti marshall on répliquera ce soir
dans la vidéo youtube exactement
pourquoi et ici les noirs qui ont joué
alors c'est pas une nouveauté mais un
coup très rare cavaliers à 5 donc il
s'en prend au four b3 mais normalement
c'est un mauvais coup mais le mauvais
coup pourquoi parce que ce cavale il
avait pour rôle de défendre le pion aux
cinq qui maintenant est lancée en prise
donc les bleus prennent les noirs en
profite pour chiper la paire de fou aux
blancs cavaliers préemption prend fou
bessette gagne un temps sur le pion eu 4
alors il faut le défendre j'imagine que
sur cavaliers c3 le problème cb4
probablement pour qu'ils attaquent le
cavalier qui devrait récupérer le pion
donc surtout bessette les bleus ont joué
t3 qui est hyper logique pour renforcer
leurs centres et leurs options eu quatre
sur quoi les noirs ont joué t5 très
typique du marshall de toutes les
ouvertures type marshall s'en prend
encore au point e 4 si on prend dame
prend dame f3 propose les changes de
dames ici les non juifs ou des six avec
l'idée de jouer dame preuve cinq dames
prend bessette et dame prend eu un échec
donc les bleus ont joué mes mates ouais
donc les blogs louis roy f1 pour
protéger la tour et sur dame prend 1,5 à
voir d'un premier set sans se faire
manger et les noirs on joue ici tour fb
8 pour protéger le fou et réitéré la
menace d'un prince inq puisque
maintenant sur d'un premier set on
aurait dame prend eu un échec au roi roi
prend le 1 et tours reprend la dame qui
serait resté en prison bessette et donc
après ça et lui les changements des 5 et
le développement comme on le disait plus
ou moins logique puisqu'on l'avait
pressenti il ya déjà un peu plus d'une
heure de cela fabien donc voilà pour le
petit résumé après 1h18 de jeu
et j'ai envie de dire
nous aussi on commence un petit peu a
bloqué on a fait le tour fab on voit pas
trop comment avancer pour le moment
on va voir
des bonbonnes nous
et
keller fine termine le match et ben
justement c'est pas le match peut être
très long finir
finir faire vers 20 heures de travail
revient 18 heures on va dire
généralement tabler sur cinq heures de
jeu en moyenne on va dire mais ça peut
très bien duré trois heures et demie
comme cette heure mais mais ce sera
normalement entre 4h30 et 6 heures
mais ce que ça va finir nul à bath ans
on n'en sait rien très franchement
c'est pas une information qu'on peut
qu'on peut te te donner
ça peut c'est pour le moment le résultat
le plus probable
comme toujours un spa lien au moment de
l'arrêt sera d'échanger deux fois pour
doubler les pions f non non c'était pas
pas suffisant les noms ont quand même un
pion - et doivent garder des pièces sur
l'échiquier d'ailleurs comme tu le vois
les noirs ne joue pas [ __ ] en f3 ici
qui reviendrait au même et parce que ça
ait changé trop de pièces ils
considèrent que leur fou est plus fort
que le cavalier en tout cas pour le
moment après ça veut pas dire qu'il le
fera pas quand vous lui
est-il un coût minimum imposé avant de
pouvoir proposer nul à la rouille lucky
jusqu'au il faut jouer jusqu'au 40e coup
pour la cbi qui se placent
inde écologique parmi tous les coups
possibles et peut-être qu'il a envie
d'avancer ces quatre un moment
car est-ce qu'on peut replacer un
cavalier vers détroit où c'est compliqué
faire qui est bien trop
[Musique]
basse et peut-être pas malin qui est
bien
mais pour essayer de repartir par allah
et
on va voir
possible en cas validé un
angle bien j'aime bien
les potiers chier
mais c'est pas
si on met tous les coups se ressemblent
enfin
fonctionner coûterait cher
pour ça qu'ils aillent aux
4e deux
cavaliers eu de hockey à l'idée c'est
faux f4 c'est encore une idée
ouais bon
c'est vrai qu'avec les noirs au final
si t'as pas de coup vraiment agressif et
que ton idée c'est juste d'attendre et
d'empêcher aux blancs d'avancé
ça peut être un peu pénible à jouer à
partir d'un certain moment quoi la faute
cédant rien faire pendant très longtemps
jamais hyper agréable
tu peux toujours faire une erreur
abandonné quoi le sommant de quitter un
moment tu y compris que c'était pas
possible on s'invente couple à bas ça
marche pas si mal on sait pas pourquoi
mais oui
je ne sais quoi donc il faut être faite
sur ses gardes avec une oreille il faut
être vigilant et je vois pas du tout
potentiel pour pour magnus de potentiel
de contre je veux dire comme tu le
disais tu fais un parallèle avec la
partie
celui de match dont contre caruana où il
y avait une grosse préparation avec
beaucoup de venant là j'arrive pas
imaginer le scénario où les noirs
prennent le dessus
wen a priori pas par eux-mêmes inspire
ciné pop reste pas trop ou pas un risque
de trop fou
pas de raison que sa position de
s'effriter
pourquoi les joueurs ne prend-il pas des
notes pendant la partie tout simplement
parce que c'est interdit
bah sinon tu peux noter des trucs pour
se souvenir
pourquoi est-ce que la pendule est
branché sur l'échiquier c'est pour
retransmettre en fait l'échiquier
digital et à il envoie les coups un
serveur donc c'est comme ça qu'on peut
avoir les coûts indirects et la pendule
est branché sur le le même le même
réseau et permet d'envoyer d'envoyer
aussi les temps restant aux deux joueurs
donc c'est pour ça que le matériel est
branché
marrant d'ailleurs n'y a toujours pas de
possibilité bluetooth non
existent mais qu'ils ont pour nous
embêter
j'ai eu une très possible dans tout ça
son film
après peut-être qu'ils imaginent que
quand il ya 45 ans tai chi et côte à
côte ça peut être un peu compliqué déjà
qu'avec les filles ça marche pas
toujours très bien
c'est pour ça qu'au tchad comme à des
horloges à l'heure où
je sais pas pourquoi ils ont pas mis les
bonnes ou les montants étaient ils ont
réajusté n'ont pas vu de temps en temps
mais pas vraiment sur
ça
tout c'est vrai que ça peut être
embêtant parce que les parties durent
longtemps aussi une question de deux
batteries
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé qu'un
joueur perde autant en partie longue
oui bien sûr
je faisais du monde j'ai pas trop en
tête mais
mais gérard candidat eelv en dessous
qu'il l'a fait trois fois en 2013 quand
même quoi
c'est beaucoup à trois fois dans la même
tendance
c'est pas mal
ma femme par le russe elle m'a dit que
nepomniachi cela veut dire ne se
souvient pas en russe c'est vrai ouais
c'est le cas
c'est ce que ça veut dire
terrible
magnus bouge par vous tous depuis dix
ans
là c'est plus que le bluetooth la face à
cinq des six jeunes
qui peut l'arrêter peut-être la cij est
il pourrait au moins faire passer les
câbles sous la table par un trou c'est
pas très noble c'est pas faux comme sur
mon comme mon studio en fait ça aurait
pu être imaginé
blier tu fais un trou dans la table mais
oui tu veux dire vraiment très complexe
oui bon oui tu as raison on va peut-être
augmenté d'un demi million le jeu et oui
et là peut-être
c'est vrai que ça aurait pu être une
solution élégante way
ma foi c'est un tournoi d'échecs et on
va pas être trop exigeant quand même
5 c'est marrant c'est chic et pas droit
moi je le remets droit généralement
bonne j'aime pas les autres n'ont pas
non plus j'aime pas c'est manquer de les
laisser de travers l'échiquier ou alors
c'est juste la cam qui donne ses
impressions
je pense pas parce que les lignes
regarde al amal donne vraiment
l'impression mais un mail et line sont
droite c'est pas possible je pense
l'échiquier vraiment travers moi ça
m'énerve
chacun laisse pour déstabiliser l'autre
je sais pas moi je le remets
naturellement
et moi ça m'embête vraiment
non mais ça fait pas de bras en fait un
après c'était une illusion d'optique
avec la cam avec une perspective mais
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'il ait pas
droit parce que les lignes sont vraiment
droite juste en dessous mais bon après
c'est parti d'un constat 13h30 il sera
de chaque jour à 13h30
c'est que les échiquiers sont jamais
vissé dans les tables non c'est le truc
qui se posent vas-y
et au milieu le la bande blanche la cpi
n'a pas on est d'accord je déteste quand
les échiquiers sont sur des nappes c'est
agréable ça please
j'aime pas du tout jeune tom blanche je
pense aussi mais je pose la question
ce
qu'ils ont le droit de toucher
l'échiquier on voit tu peux adoubé
l'échiquier c'est à environ
et la pendule n'est pas tout à fait
centre et non plus
la pendule ça me choque pas en vrai
tu touches et chic et sans la double et
il faut le jouer après c'est beaucoup de
taper
ouais mais écoute
j'ai envie de dire on a fait le tour de
tout ça fait à peu près une heure vingt
qu'on est bloqués sur cette position à
quelque chose près
ce qu'il faut attendre encore une petite
heure 45 voire deux heures non mais
je pense qu'ils ont encore une heure
quarante deux heures à passer à peu près
sur cette position et après peut-être y
aura une évolution mais il va pas se
passer grand chose là dans l'est dans
les deux heures à venir à mon avis à
moins d'une gaffe ou quoi ça peut
toujours arriver
ben badis que ce n'est pas utile yeux de
jeu quand j'ai regardé sur le téléphone
tout à l'heure je crois que c'est le
plan que propose écrit tchouk la chaîne
en russe j'ai vu ça en passant
donc oui pas idiot un jeu tout propose
oui c'est le plan que great flu qui est
en train de montrer way pour peut-être
du coup je veux fiat re oui d'après
demain c'est d'après les flèches qui
avait en fait il manque à merlieux un
fouet f4 on sait quand et à quelle date
il faut être quatre
il est vraiment très fin aux
commentaires il faut vraiment mieux que
d'habitude
j'ai juste vu l'idée des grilles chuck 1
ap 4 mois cet échange avec la smart est
content a priori il va partir il va
envoyer souffre en hi-fi tout ça est
faux pas échanger et
[Musique]
et après tout cas il pourra rebondir
peut-être aller vers j'ai trois ou
quatre
on
verra bien notre indiqué aux 4
on verra bien il ya des moments où
ça bloque un peu hein on peut pas sûr
anticipe une truc mais un peu ce que
disent les autres qui commentent en fait
en même temps oui ou voiliers carreaux
et sow qui commentent bon
gardien c'est 6 ça c'est étonnant
ou partie
les polonais qui va du fief quoi 3 aussi
ça fait la cuisine
c'est beaucoup à stream cuisine à
chanter à lyon c'est magnifique à 3,7 à
62 centimes
magnifique der la recette écho plus à 62
centimes
bon qui sait si je suis un peu étonné du
coup je sais pas trop pourquoi
après tu peux revenir des cats à tout
moment oui mais bon pour partir du coup
bon après ça change pas des masses
c'est complexe
cavalli sait si j'avais pas trop dans l'
orange à vrai dire non je pensais que
c'était bien le sens du 4s pas bougé
pendant ce qu'ils avaient peur de fou
prend b4 au final genre ce qui fait on
va dire un coucou je pars oil fuite
je vous prends nous
j'ai pas se retrouver de peur mais bon
j'ai
appris comment ça avance avec les
blanches est ce que fo et 4,5 ou
qu'ils se contractent y une prophétie
profonde d'une fois fait quatre ans
que l'on nous avait fait 4
kg 6 à moins apparaître dessinée conte
fou prend b4 je vois pas
l'intérêt de 4 d'ailleurs c'est peut
expliquer pourquoi il a fait deux
tournées avant qu'ils étaient trop
bas il faut qu'on regarde un peu plus
profondément là
à
[Musique]
ce que
j'aime en fuite celle qu'on voulait
faire en fait nous faut prendre ça prend
et après
en fait c'est vrai que maintenant qu'il
a mis sept tours ans et 8 et que toi tu
as gardé la tour en un plus grand bassin
bonjour partira à 8 un jour et tu veux
cavaliers 1 qui a validé 3
c3 est avance
petit à petit
j'y crois pas trop mais un
jeu [ __ ]
ce que serait pas d'époque est en train
de dominer
ok on va tout de suite voir de façon
aussi fait cavalier b4 c'est qu'il
voulait empêcher prend
donc faut 3 qu'est ce que ça fait c'est
dès qu'un pressions menaces des cats à
l'hiver la caisse des deux têtes dans le
fief 3 j'ai plein de choses
bizarres cette partie pour le moment
difficile en fait parce que
les coûts sont pas
naturels
n'ont pas trop eu
ordures
[Musique]
le truc c'est que si tu fais québécois
je vois pas du tout comment les blancs
avance mais bon peut-être qu'il fait y
font des quatre et ils commencent à
avancer la jambe gauche va le prendre
dans le guen
qui avait là ça commence à être mieux
pour les blancs quand même mais toujours
faire ses trois des quatre fixe du feu
qui avait troqué ses 5 août approche je
fais des trucs
étranges un étrange qui est en train de
faire ma news quand même
nom mais le truc bizarre c'est que
j'aurais dit et que tu crains pas formé
quatre et que si tu ne crains du coup
sauf à remettre en question le setup oui
peut-être tour des huit tours assez vite
n'était pas très bien pensée vrai
mais c'est bizarre pour quelqu'un qui
avait l'air si bien préparée de rater
son set up weeps normalement en fait il
connaît pas que les coups il sait où se
placer et en profondeur la vision qu est
ce que je peux échanger comment quand
bon c'est difficile à dire pour le
moment parce que la position a l'air
très profonde et les joueurs pensent à
beaucoup de coups mais ça a pas l'air
d'être une grande partie de carlson pour
le modèle il tombe la veste bah voila
tu vois il n'y a pas que nous qui avons
eu l'impression d'un problème
dans leur genre l'horlogerie et
norvégienne
satik s'attaque mais pas forcément comme
il faut
étrangers tranche parce que les coups
semblent à contresens un peu alors voici
un rien de grave encore mais scénario de
la partie qui fait penser ça
bah oui parce qu'en fait tu as
l'impression que tu as fait tour à 6,8
machin que finalement ça a donné du fou
prend b4 dans leur âge que maintenant te
fait cavalier c6 que lui tu fais fou ou
trois
mais tout d'un coup tu as du d4 qui se
présentent tu peux avoir du cash est roi
kiev 5 kg trois cavaliers ou quatre pour
taper ici
mais ça donne l'impression d'un on va
pas dire craquage le mot est fort mais
d'une fébrilité côté norvégien
bah disons
il a un bizarrement pas l'air de savoir
exactement comment gérer la position
c'est ça
ça donne l'impression qu'il est pas sûre
de ses coûts qui n'est pas sûr de lui
j'ai pas sûr du chemin employés
ont dit que c'est complètement égal
d'après leur dit non et ça c'est évident
que c'est complètement égal
mais
d'après leur dit qu il tient ça mais ce
dont on parle c'est pas de l'évaluation
de leurs 10 et les coûts qui viennent
d'être joués et comme disait mur tu as
mon entraîneur c'est un petit peu comme
un combat de boxe sûr que là ça donne
l'impression qu'ils sont à égalité au
point
les derniers qui ont été assénés par par
le joueur russe après c'est rien de
grave hein tu peux te remettre enfin là
il va dans son coin soumise à un petit
peu dowell rocky vos
trucs verts tournoi aux malades je
retrouve il repart ça va mais non c'est
plutôt lui qui a perdu le dernier round
je souhaite belles années 2000 27 la
pollution at elle un peu avancé en
réalité oui
il ya eu un petit contresens côté côté
carole scène
comme s'ils ne sont pas très grave parce
que c'est que quand bien même tu réussis
à faire des quatre est tous avec les
fous qui tape ça semble difficile de
remettre la marche avant mais bon c'est
trois bécane des gens tu fixes d'un
petit caïd assez simple avance un petit
peu
pour moi qui avais 5 c'est du pur flex
il y en a marre d'être champion du monde
ou la non
safer d'être assez fort le cavalier à
cinq quand même
pas d'autre choix qui les trésors d'être
champion du monde je crois que c'est ce
qui justifie team son objectif ultime
après
alors c'est encore tôt pour en parler
mais peut-être qu'il a un petit peu
négligé la préparation au niveau du
milieu de jeu ça me semble quand même
étonnant la part de magnus on sait que
c'est un joueur qui est très méticuleux
fabien
mais il ay est est ce que moi j'ai pris
son excès de confiance pour du bluff
enfin personnellement j'ai pensé que
dans ses interviews il avait l'air très
confiant avant match et c'était du bluff
pour un petit peu provoquer né pour un
petit pain petit peu à l'image d'un
morpheus dans matrix 1 donc ouais
j'avais pris c'est un petit peu comme
une provocation et qu'il ne pensait pas
vraiment les mots qui disait mais si
c'est vraiment ce qu'ils pensaient
qu'ils sentaient autant favori ce serait
moins étonnant de l'avoir vu comme ça un
petit peu négligents
ouais bon après tout quand même des gens
autour de lui les épaules ouais mais je
pense que manu c'est quand même un petit
peu le le roi entre guillemets kiki
assal cours autour de lui quand même un
bon nul chez nous quoi bon faire quand
on t'a vu comment robespierre a fini
les mecs qu'ils aient fait gaffe pierre
tu vas peut-être un peu loin
non non ça reste inquiète je gère
pitié quand même
donc non je ne sais pas tu as que
nielsen a vraiment encore
encore le pouvoir
après je voyais comme je disais un mois
j'ai pas j'ai pas fais très attention à
ses conférences de presse à ses
interviews parce que j'ai vraiment pris
ça pour du bluff tu bluffes marthonie
mais bon marthonie me bluffer par un
maintenant il non il n'a qu'une balle un
vrai
[Musique]
wba
or ces temps de faire de le voir aussi à
biars qui fait 24 degrés à dubaï alors
peut-être que la salle est climatisée un
probablement
un mehdaoui alors qu'il trouve un coup
en fait tu dis qu'ils aillent pkt le
coup logique à vrai dire même pourquoi
pas retenu mais peut-être avez peur de
vous prendrez quand même fait sept
heures de fou prend big ben en fait il
ya quelque part un problème c'est que la
bourse est à péter mauvais ou
ce qu'il ya d'autres calmes alors oui
alors attends je peux je peux les mettre
petit à petit il faut juste que je fasse
un petit un petit réglage pour nous
avoir sur les autres cam non un family
qui apparaît et un kiev
dans des poules 2 km j'ai fait n'importe
quoi femmes fallait pas faire comme ça
mais on voit karl scène en grand pour
attendez je mets un fabliau un cave
ambulant
je fais complètement n'importe quoi
femme robot soir c'est ça il faudrait
marche
je crois que c'est en train de marcher
femmes ouais
je fais n'importe quoi
cette big man
je pense que j'ai pas très bien cliquer
et recliquer
c'est pas grave hein
le problème sexuel j'ai mis un maximum
de choses en place mais
comme au lieu d'envoyer hier les caméras
et où ils ont tout envoyé ce matin
n'est pas au millimètre près quoi mais
même si j'ai commencé à 7h30
même si j'ai commencé à 7h30 c'était pas
évident de tout faire alors il fait
cavalier set
et ça sent le contresens quand même où
va-t-il
il en retire un ver des cinq pour aller
enfin
petits losanges que juste pour montrer
la blague parce que certains qui n'ont
pas la réf en fait le cavalier viande et
donc qui par an il est parti en c6 et ça
donne l'impression qu'il va revenir en
recettes pour repartir vers des 5es pour
retourner vers p4 quand même
un infini si l'infini
alors je pense que soit l'idée parce que
tu aurais pu repasser par b 4 pour
allant des cinq donc l'idée ne va pas
être de venir en d5 et peut-être d'aller
au f5 et au cas où en dessin que je me
mets une fois f5 il valait ou est ce qui
peut avoir du fou prend cavaler h4 dans
le règne
alors il veut revenir vers des 4 1 les
amis puisqu'ils étaient déjà qui veut
pas aller comme ça il pouvait y aller en
un seul coup
ils pouvaient ils pouvaient pas trop oui
enfin divisé dès l'été prochain a
déclaré
si on fait flouer 4 c'est un coup
logique puisque sa force les changes
ouais alors dit
marie claude guillotte qu'on regardait
déjà des changes les chevaux et
lectoure d66 enfin celle là je te cache
pas qu'on va un peu la joue et quand
même on a vraiment besoin de plus après
que s'il veut faire taxer pour ce
sixième venir vers ces sages si ce n'est
qu'elle alourdit d'un égal mais un
ok mais tu joue tout le temps ça avec
les blancs montés comprendre
ça tu fais tour un scam plus en plus net
non mais je vous dit un truc en fait je
cavale elle s'inquiète des quatre ils te
tape là si tu fais c3 est vrai qu'il est
prend b3 et après on fait ça va pour les
noirs mais c'est hyper dur à comprendre
mais bon peut-être qu'ils accueillent
réfléchir
qantas a en tout cas fouet f4 serait la
première la première idée quand on
active avec les blancs ça ne fonctionne
pas
on nous dit que l'ordi kif cavaliers g3
burgenland en page 5
un temps va essayer de choper on va on
va refaire le jeu aux nombreuses mais
avec les pauvres
cette gamme est assez sympa je trouve
réussir à faire la même chose assez
facilement je pense
ouais
donc allégé 3 serait une option
belle qualité de cadre à énoncer ses
traits et c'est très bien filmé c'est
ses propres l'image est propre l'image
est bien travaillé une belle colomé tri
fabien ça c'est important important la
colo mettrie toujours je pense qu'à une
belle pub qui parent pour les calmes bah
oui plus de trois minutes la histoire
d'un petit peu souffler
au moins où lé cam seront set up pour la
suite exactement
après j'ai quand même c'est top beaucoup
de choses hein ce matin pour pour avoir
les cannes pour tout avoir qui cadre
bien
qu'il ya quand même du boulot qui a été
fait mais oui j'ai pas eu le temps d'
absolument tout faire
c'était un peu un peu court un peu nigel
un peu short un peu short way
sur cavaliers g3 rouzic la turbine veut
cavaliers des 5èmes ça m'étonne pas je
serai beaucoup si j'ai 3 qui a été 5 fu
d2 qui a et b 4 n'était qu'une
répétition
a une ambition que meta
metaverse non mais tu assures logo la
[Musique]
dédicace
on est planté en pleine réflexion
il est concentré le joueur russe
la tête rivés sur l'échiquier il doit
sentir un lui aussi que magnus n'est pas
dans ça dans sa meilleure forme tu le
vois à claques des coups sont pas sont
pas logiques d'ailleurs il aurait pu
faire cavaler des cinq qui avait lieu
cette directement on n'en a pas parlé
ouais mais il faut en d2 je me dis oui
mais bon j'en parle avec ça ce sens là
car un truc qui va pas
j'ai entendu comme il se passe pas grand
chose tu as le temps de faire des trucs
dont je lui avais dit à droite à gauche
mais tu vois petite moue cyr concept
circonspect
circonspecte circonspecte merci fab
donné peau qui se pose sur son pouce
possède
cette position la poussette femmes
avec le pouce qui tient le menton
ouais
tout un édifice
du coup c'est tellement pas confortable
non
pour le pousse dans notre illustre
trémuson ça paraît plus confortable
cette position
ce cas position sur le pouce
askar assez particulier quoi
papa est fascinante en sus pouces
qu'est-ce qui boit
japhet
match à
un petit match à qui pourrait partir à
tout moment fab a eu une très bonne idée
puisqu'ils coach
en tout cas c'est j'ai envie de te dire
il a peut-être une occasion en or là
n'est pas sain car le cncs là c'est pas
impressionnant
il faut qu'ils réussissent à pousser
quoi [ __ ] idy pas conne
farfouille g5
d'accord admettant prog et 6 ouais
vraiment réfléchi être même lignée la
tour soit 6e le taf épluchées à venir là
bas
[Musique]
il sera obligé de faire tour 6 m pour
défendre le pion ouais
c'est l'impression qu'on avait mais t'as
plutôt assistera à 6 tours je ne sais au
détail sympa pour nous
ça peut être une bonne idée ça fab
ça peut être une idée correcte que tu
viens de nous et non ses
moi j'ai travaillé vocabulaire un peu
c'est le festival
ses fins sa femme notre faim lafleur
vision riou
eepad après leur a dit oui mais bon fab
est plus fort donc
pourquoi
probalement faut pas faire et 6 heures
mais c'est le coup le plus logique vinci
monte cloué quoi
et peut-être je vous fais ton cavaliers
ramé matour cervin le faire des coups
normaux
ouais non c'est une option clairement
cavaliers g3 le coût de 2 cc soit l'art
d'être juste rentrer mais un vice de 4
tu vises f ce que tu défends f5
tu as quand même un pion plus avec les
blancs au final est pour le moment les
noirs font pas le taf un
mois les attendent nathan
or mais sa position reste
non c'est ce qu'on disait vrai la
position des doigts restent corrects
mais les derniers coups sont inquiétants
pour pour les supporters du joueur au
drapeau tricolore le rouge le blanc et
le bleu
aussi les tricolores mais le nôtre aussi
et c'est les mêmes couleurs ces mêmes
couleurs pâles en ce sens même sens
prédominance de rouge quand même côté
côté norvégien
une petite chrome ie alors que les
russes c'est vraiment les mêmes couleurs
que nous
lance je faisais gabon vous faudra bien
mais faire mais a priori tous les
échanges
vous râlez pour les noirs
ce qui intéresse c'est qu'on nous
demande souvent combien de coups de
calculer joueur à l'as vence à vrai dire
la pas beaucoup
il peut faire beaucoup
je sais pas en fait ils cherchent
comment placer les pièces
ils cherchent des agencements aurait
plus tôt
ouais ça ça calcul ça réfléchit en tout
cas de dépôt qui normalement devrait
être moins à l'aise que carlson dans ce
type de position et comme tu l'as dit
qu'il pourrait être nerveux et jouer
vite il est quand même très bien rentré
dans son match finalement malgré en plus
une frayeur dans l'ouverture
il fait sa partie
on va voir un on va voir ça donne
[Musique]
il peut gagner cette partie dépôt on en
parlera toujours plus tôt sur nul
mais sait-on jamais
ouais et puis là quasiment enlever la
défaite
des résultats possibles dans cette
partie il ya nepomniachi le joueur russe
et c'est déjà important surtout dans une
première partie de championnat du monde
n'a pas envie de perdre perdre avec les
longs des bus man quoi
ouais ça s'arrête à ça
j'irai pas que ça hypothéquerait toutes
ses chances dans ce match on est paumé
savait que perdre au plan la première
partie
c'est pas très bon signe abbas il y
avait 30 ou 35 % de chances de gagner le
match avant le début en tout cas c'est
ce que lui donner les bookmakers
britanniques
après une défaite au blanc à la première
t à quoi tu es à 5 10% maximum
donc oui ça ferait très mal alors que la
victoire aux blancs ils monteraient à
45% chose comme ça
car c'est impossible de faire glisser le
fou noir en f6
pourquoi pas un jour c'est pas une
mauvaise idée
après ça m'a un peu de travail il faut
enlever le cahier de 7 mètres le fond de
cette 29ème 67.3 tendre évidemment les
blancs le temps
rend le temps d'agir mais c'est pas un
mauvais placement bon choix
ouais non ce serait plusieurs sous que
c'est pas le plan sur lequel il est
parti pour le moment
il n'est pas parti sur fouet cette fois
f6 magnus là il est parti sur qui a et b
4 qui essaient si ce qui a valu aux sept
québec des cinq québécois pour le moment
on peut peut-être mettre là la position
aussi comme cela fab
voir un visuel sur l'échiquier qui est
toujours pas droit
aux mêmes titres en sorte que ce point
comme
ouais je crois qu'il a
signé un contrat avec chace comme on le
voit
sur sa chemise
il se met bien yann
il se mettrait bien yann un petit pion
vers
sabots un petit peu d'eau côté yann
c'est sérieux c'est solide ça suffira
peut-être pas aujourd'hui il pourra
ressortir quand même inquiet de sa
préparation de l'ouverture où il semble
s'être fait prendre mais il sera rassuré
un quoi qu'il en soit ok ça va que dans
le jeu il n'est pas en dessous après il
mène dans les parties longues contre
magnus carlsen quatre victoires à une
donc quelque part c'est vrai que magnus
a montré beaucoup de confiance mais yann
il doit se dire je ne comprends pas oui
pour une 4 1 de quoi tu es confiant quoi
après bon c'est beaucoup de partis quand
il était plus jeune évidemment ça compte
article historique comme dirait le
philosophe français va de quatre chefs
on n'oublie pas les traces du passé
mon philosophie un tout à fait un moment
que ça ira forcément à 14 parties en
fait non un joueur dépasserait 7 points
donc à sept mois et demi huit ou quoi
c'est fini
ça c'est quand même une bonne décision
grand chose servirait pas à grand chose
de continuer
pourquoi on continuerait de 10 matches
en huit parties minimum mais n'en voudra
sûrement une bonne dizaine peut être ira
jusqu'au bout te rattrape tu m'en sors
avancé minimum
je pense pas qu'il ya un massacre ou un
mec va tout perdre non plus
mais normalement tu vas jusqu'à la
douzième no way
mais tranche dont jouer moins que 12 un
peu probable
ça semble un minimum
parce que je pense 7,5 non mais enfin
même 7,5 en fait tu joueras encore
toujours encore la 13e ouais c'est pour
ça que j'ai eu en jouant au moins 12 à
mon avis
et ça paraîtrait étonnant qui est un
genre de
7,2
ça ça me paraîtrait quand même assez
assez étonnant
ça réfléchit
encore et encore c'est que le début
d'accord d'accord
c'est sa femme
que le début
parce que faire un brésil allemagne
vu comment ça par là ça m'étonnerait
et oui après tout est possible
vous croyez pas que même si ce n'est pas
gagné les gens continuent à consommer
magnus comme le vrai champion
non le concert est peut-être encore
comme le meilleur joueur du monde mais
comme le vrai champion non vers un match
des plus champions enfin c'est un tueur
est numéro 1 mondial ne mettait pas
champion du monde il fait frais 4,4 dont
classé turbo égalisation après fou prend
prisé tour66 vague du se trouve c'est
nul direct
ça paraissait vraiment fort ça paraît
bien pour les normes et très bon fabien
deglise
je pense qu'il va faire oui je pense à
toi t'as pas le choix j'ai d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'il l'a déjà dit ouais c'est
ce truc soit lens orange est bon pour
nous c'était facile
maintenant pourquoi frêche 4 coup
d'avant bah je sais pas non plus de huit
ans et six
à vrai dire c'est qu'il partait plutôt
pour cavaliers g3 de base
mais en fait je comprends pas ce qu'ils
font les couples oui j'ai beaucoup de
mal expliqué ce qui se passe ce chaque
coup un peu trop à savoir si robin la
ceinture gaudreault fab
la montagne a accouché d'une souris ou
la souris a accouché d'une montagne
ça le fait moins petite montagne alors
non la très mal joué de la part de yann
on n'a pas trop compris la partie en
vrai à vrai dire je varende a compris
que ce débat gloire comme position comme
est ce que l'on je n'aurais pas dépasser
le jeu finalement
mathieu mais que ceux ci préfèrent même
les noirs
pour savoir
vont te son lit de prendre
bizarre cette partir ouais elle allait
vraiment bizarre
une partie sans queue ni tête exactement
c'est fini tôt alors finito non c'est
fini tôt pour l' avantage de yann
arrive le pour yann il n'a pas compris
il couvre votre nom il n'a pas compris
y a pas compris il a toujours pas
compris qu'il était pas moins qu'ils
n'étaient plus mieux et peut-être même
un peu moins bien ça peut être dangereux
du coup pour pour yann
parisien comprendre vous a priori on est
content
on a un avion de plus en échange à
perdre fouad verse on à la torah qui
joue son pion à 6 ont beaucoup de choses
qui après récent sympa le problème c'est
qu'on l'a dit les normes votre une tour
sur cydia ne sait pas laquelle je dirais
c'est moi
et
[Musique]
en fait ça coulisses le cavalier au
stade du coup il va revenir vers f5 et
d4 et les pions blancs qui de vases sont
par son style fait bon se dit bon mais
le ranger de quoi bon ben là bas se
pendre des échecs à 5 h 4 etc etc
alors pas si simple
ouais c'est ce inquiétant prg en dépôt
on va à vrai dire il a une chance dans
cette partie est 6e à souffrir je vois
pas quand et comment est ce qui va
gagner une partie faire [ __ ] ils
changent de stratégie en fait c'est ce
qu'on l'avait dit en début de match il
faut qu'ils jouent des positions à
l'année paula il a joué des positions à
la carte zen et même un karl scène paf
en bout flamboyant
va finalement réussir à le neutraliser
sans trop de soucis
ben écoute on va voir mais c'est sûr que
le tour soit 6
il faut qu'ils arrêtent d'être plus être
pas le choix de l'espagnol dont la
trouve un petit peu plus tout de suite
après car là ça n'a pas semblé
a pas semblé en bonne forme mais n'est
peau il saisit pas l'occasion quoi
admin tu as dit que c'était inquiétant
pour carlson bah oui mais c'est comme si
une équipe de foot
pour cela elle dominé et est là elle
vient de mettre trois frappes cadrées et
que l'action d'après elle se prend un
but bon bah forcément
ça devient ça devient inquiétant pour
pour l'équipe qui vient d'encaisser le
but là
clairement
carlson n'ai pas l'impression de jouer
les coups les plus précis et enée pop
italie là il a fait encore pire qu il
vient de faire une ba une gaffe mais une
une vraie erreur voilà ce cadre il
laisse une chance de simplifier devant
un truc pas mal
c'est clairement une faute
il est donc voilà on va voir maintenant
faut il fait oublier davantage vous
jouez pour juste juste faire droit
ouais c'est ça le truc c'est qu'il
dominait enfin karlsson a dominé
l'ouverture donc au début on était un
peu inquiet pour les peaux justement aux
mondes un dépôt c'est prendre dans
l'ouverture il se retrouve dans un
terrain qu'il connaît pas trop puis
après il ya cette phase de début de
milieu de jeu qui est plutôt dominé par
le joueur russe dont onze y tient car la
scène pas rentrer dans le match et la
grosse erreur et il s car le sel du
maître pression est là à vrai dire il va
falloir qu'ils fassent attention yann
parce que c'est le genre de position que
même le cas c'est même bien ouais
donc là il faudrait il va falloir serrer
le jeu et pas et pas se retrouver à
apprendre une catastrophe surtout qui
s'est relevé après tour c6
il a l'air d'être très confiant je crois
qu'il n'a pas compris l'étendue des
dégâts encore yann et c'est ça le plus
inquiétant c'est qui quand tu sais que
c'est dangereux red69 tu vas prendre les
mesures mais là j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'a pas encore pris la mesure d'un
regard ils jouent tous tempo
c'est que c'est comme ça que tu peux
perdre une promeneuse chine
il n'a pas compris la position jan il se
lève il croit qu'il est mieux
marché amm et des curieux en fait dans
le hockey mais juste faut arrêter de
jouer des finales
non mais il croit qu'il est gagnant là
quasiment
non mais il a pas compris en fait aux le
malaise rô le malaise il croit qu'il est
mieux le frérot alors qu'il a deux
doigts d'être perdants au c'est terrible
mais il est nommé femme s'il continue
comme ça il va la perdre
1 me croient y croit il croit qu'il est
pression
est là rien capté quoi car la cei doit
lui si
j'en ai même pas rajouter dans mes
conférences de presse les mecs c'est à
peine bouger les pièces non mais c'est
terrible à ce qui fait qu'elles n'ont eu
un bon tournant sa
détention pour défendre ces deux mois on
ne fait plus rien thompson cole ouverte
il va revenir ça sent il va dire alors
me voilà venue assez vite le coucou me
choque pas quoi
tu as 30 5 équivalents 10,4
deux assurent qu'ils changent d'avis pas
encore ouais marche arrière
merde
j'ai essayé ça fait pas bien comme il y
avait peut-être détourage schiste on
n'était pas bien en fait
pour nous c'est facile on à l'éval de
l'ordi donc c'est beaucoup plus simple
mais investissements qui en
gms qui autorise quatre tours aux sept
ans un rituel qui arrange et un tube
blindés mais regarde on se jouer
roscoff attention attention yann prend
le mur de thé nul qui par fab
bah oui mais il sera c'est me crois
qu'il est gagnant
n'y croit qu'il est un pion puissent
s'aimer pression jeudi ajouté mme pour
wii et des cinq thèmes 20 millions on
voit tout tempo
il va se faire défoncer en fait non mais
c'est n'importe quoi ce qui fait la
hitchcock complètement au hall malaise
non mais c'est n'importe quoi
ce qu'il veut potes qui dit non mais en
fait j'ai assez clairement kikwete mon
coup là je suis plus quoi nichée quoi en
fait je suis plus non mais c'est un vrai
choc ça en fait line choc
ben j'ai envie de te dire le match de
championnat du monde pour être fini déjà
ce soir fab mais là s'il prend la
cartouche ah oui père
s'y perd
j'appelle la vidéo ce de ce soir magnus
carlsen vs il ya nulle ognami achik
m
mais là il peut perdre mais j'ai en fait
tu peux pas enfin tu peux pas en finale
de championnat du monde juste rien
comprendre
on va voir ça tu comprends très bien et
mieux que nous
c'est un passant qui correctement nul
j'ai envie de jouer en match je suis sûr
je leur âge le fish
un truc en fait là ça pourrait être une
situation psychologique quoi cette année
noire signée compromis carlson c'est pas
le genre n'ont
jamais complètement con
carne scène il envie de défoncer là je
te le dis tout de suite
mais ça sent le fish quand même
à mon avis tu mets maso avec les noirs
là
ça chante un
quart seulement rajoute en plus il fait
le mec qui souffrent mais tellement ça
carlos est il en train de lui faire un
acteur studio on croit et leonardo
dicaprio quoi
regarder ni carla ni l'entrée lui dire
certaines choses n'ont pas de prix pour
le reste il ya eurocard mastercard à mon
avis
prévoyons selon vous à la il en train de
l'île en train de le master card dead
quoi
maintenant en train de défoncer quoi
cinépop j'y crois plus du tout
grave de personnes la perdre ça c'est
mais je pense qu'il ya déjà 20 % de
victoires carlson dans leur âge
me
[Musique]
s'étonnant qu'il soit achevée aussi vite
année tout d'un coup
c'est complètement stupide il a réfléchi
des plombes pour faire des coups on
faire découvrir un autre c'est pareil
mais là là le prix des coûts augmenter
qua non mais en plus le type de position
a complètement changé la structure a
changé le rapport mater la changer tout
a changé et tu fous tout impôt
montrez-nous la ligne mais n'y a pas de
ligne en fait
c'est juste c'est un peu dangereux
problème lancé jusqu'à 24 ça va attaquer
là ça va attaquer là je sais pas tu fais
tour 3 tu bloques
je précise pour tours f6 été vite les
maths du couloir et il y aura plus de
cavaliers h5 et
ça sent que c'est agréable là disons du
fairway eux deux pour couvrir
je sais pas trop ton décidé
parce que ça sera pour qui les 5 revient
peut-être g5y tu viens de cavaliers en
tout cas les blancs ils sont clairement
en train de défendre tu vas jamais rien
avancer dans la position peut-être tu
vas pas perdre c'est parce qu'on dit
mais ça devient chiant à jouer pour les
blancs au rck de bosses et l inverse et
blanc quand même besoin de plus et alors
que doit faire un peu plus graves ah oui
ce qui est inquiétant c'est enfin c'est
même pas ça si c'est ça mais c'est
s'allier au fait qu'ils vous tous tempo
observe que tu as l'impression qu'ils se
rend pas compte des potentiels va être
maintenant là si tu veux un coup à côté
tu peux juste le geste armes alors
que pression encore en soit il ya pas
mort d'homme
tu files notons que c'est ça ouais
oui mais bon si je t'aime pas il ya
peut-être une idée mais justement ça qui
est inquiétant est que la wii c'est là
en fait faut comprendre que tu as mal
jouer serré la vis et faire nul
et la carte celle en fait clairement ils
essayent plus de chercher la nuit là
maintenant il essaye de chercher un truc
ça
pince parce qu'on dit un peu quand même
nom du launay achi c'est pas hyper cool
on a ici la perdre et on allait mettre
ça même pas dit qu'ils allaient perdre
enfin toute façon il faut bien qu'on
dise des choses parce qu'il ya pas mal
de choses à raconter non plus qu enfin
les cannes deux heures et demi qu'on est
sur un truc jai casse-cou quoi on
s'entend l'ouverture enfin j'ai pas
abandonner
alors j'ai 5 intéressant et pour lui
d'être un produit offert tour aux cinq
de ces tours 5 ouais ça je suis quasi
sûr bref tout ça pour des trois-tours f4
r
ça c'est peut-être qu'il espère niveau
je pense qu'arsène peut-être intérêts
bon déjà il veut faire ça et nulles
nulles ou avec les north pas mal soit
sinon il peut tenter de la pressée
mettre un peu d acer sous pression truc
désagréable ce que ce qu'on attendait
juste avant comme position phare
questions l'image à la frise ou magnus
il bouge plus
on parie
[ __ ]
l'homme de marbre
marbre aide
aussi impressionnant
il bouge plus il ya quelqu'un qui va le
réveiller se passe quoi si on respire
crois c'est flippant
au la puissance de calcul
oh ça fait très très mal
c'est beau quand même parce qu'on sent
on sent l'effort intellectuel un feu
l'effort physique là qui est produit par
magnus ah ça fait penser vraiment un
cycliste dans l'alpe d'huez fab dans
l'est dans les derniers lacets là bas
ils bougent plus d'être à défendre
contre la montre peut-être même ouais
ouais non la l'effort est vraiment
intense on le sent un la la
concentration est tel que ça que ça
bouge plus d'un iota hausse incroyable
l'homme statue au musée grévin d'
mais musée grévin des
femmes j'y peux rien c'est musée grévin
tu sais pas si c'est vrai ou si c'est un
homme de sirlin
bah oui mais je n'y a pas un regard plus
en mouvement c'est impressionnant
voiture mais c'est pour ça que j'aurais
moi j'aurais mis jours de repos dès
demain un bon
parce que là on sent vraiment l'effort
intellectuel qui est qui est en train
d'être produit il est quasiment en apnée
je me demande si refesse ici respire
encore
sa caméra qui bouge ouais c'est la
caméra qui bouge c'est pas magnus norman
n'a pas tenu
ah ça c'est impressionnant
ça impressionnant
ça fait combien de temps déjà ça fait
minimum deux minutes donc ils bougent
plus comme ça est ce si on met une pub
la pub s'arrête et il bouge 1 est ce qu
est ce qu une pub peut le relancer je
tente est-ce qu'on lançant une pub ça
relance magnus ou pas
est-ce qu'une coupure de pub relancer
magnus
vas-y est lancé
non non non non ça marche pas il y
médusé quoi
bien sûr en train c'est la mi-temps à 30
secondes de pub j'ai pas de bloc
terrible
terrible tu vas y souffrent un petit peu
tu as trop longtemps ça va plus vite le
couple et dans son effort et
chance pour n'est peut-être
ça souffle à
risque ortiz and chic crise cortisone
magnifique
tout cas partie parties passionnantes
jusqu'à maintenant fab se passe il se
passe beaucoup beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui cette première partie du
championnat du monde à tous pas une
nouveauté incroyable de magnus carlsen
sens une position très complexe on n'a
pas compris grand chose on n'avait pas
le niveau puis une gaffe de nepomniachi
gars faites gaffe à est une erreur une
erreur de dépôt et maintenant nez peau
qui dans le rôle de la proie face face
aux chasseurs
tirent des glaces
et
la du kun hee peau qui ne sait même pas
que il est dans le rôle de la proie
maintenant c'est un peu l'anti l'homme
tranquille ouais c'est on dit là bas si
peu d'herbe
vient brouter un petit peu
attention
ça arrive en tout cas côté côté carl
scène c'est sérieux un côté norvégien
demande si c'est magnus lund sommes pas
tableau publicitaires
je vous demanderais de vous calmer dans
le tchat
moi je trouve que au contraire c'est
tout c'est tout c'est logo i gueye un
petit peu sa chemise noire
donc c'est un peu pesant de formule 1
est neutre ouais oui complètement égayer
quoi tu veux de mastercard meltwater
voulait mettre le casque soit servant
qu'un peu de total oui petit total
energy tu vois qui part peut-être pour
la suite de votre un peu de rouge
l'autre côté rennes puis à énergie
dedans donc tu sens que ça te booste
total toi t'es tu es bien quoi un peu de
orange un peu dessus je suis pas nerveux
tout quoi va rater bien dans liquide
ouais
plus grand des hasards
qui
qualifie l'algérie savez-vous quoi
surtout
cook ou pas cap lacaille je suis hostile
où le cac 40 a aussi pas très bien quoi
nasdaq atvi dia
est ce que tu viennes et ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est un peu moins bon mais
bon
c'est magnifique alpha
sur le coeur bat oui
avec une photo de baky le prez les
drapeaux du baptiste en d'autres
temps sur le court arthur ashe
je crois que d'efolia sur le siège
partout la même le mur tel truc la photo
je sais pas cette année mais je sais que
quand je bosse à la fidh en fait la
bouteille aussi c'est un sponsor
ouais c'est aussi obligatoire de l'avoir
à la caméra avec des sponsors de partout
ses clientes pas ça quand même remettre
les panneaux lumineux je pense que
c'est beau
mais bon on va voir car il a l'âge
d'être sage ou pas là nul ici
pour trois tops ou je sais pas si
ce que tu souffles six minutes pas
mais del vasto c'est magnifique ça fait
plaisir bah oui et c'est quoi est fait
le tour des matchs du coup cela on voit
pas trop défaut sa grossesse
qu'elle me rappelant large peut-être oui
un algo rang phosagro
nom et que deux
petits trucs qui ressemble à l'heure aux
uv qui ce temps mes
chronos et phosagro parce qu'en fait
c'est d'agriculture un jour ça expo du
bay
away simple ouais mais c'est peut-être
financé par baky un
bien finir avesnes sont nombreux de
faire vendre comme
kaspersky aussi
juste sur la table ah oui et ils sont
pas derrière
ils ont dû payer que pour la table est
né pauvre les sponsors chess club est en
fait jusqu'à on ne voit même pas faim
jusqu'à 1000 enfin rennes l'oeil mais on
voit pas son logo
on le voit pas
quand même si le tempo là on le voit
bien rien
enfin pour le savoir
il à la rose du fossat broadway
mais ça sur le ciel je pense que c'est
le nom mais sur ces
cinq gros il est une sorte de requins
n'ont encore et on va peut-être laissé
cette gamme pourra bien le look autres
chaises comme brodés
et ça qui est un peu pauvre mêmes savez
ça n'est pas terrible non une petite
veste est là enfin je suis un peu moche
bon dieu pourquoi pas enfin
c'est spécial qu'on veut dire enfin acer
dauphin il un dauphin ouais c'est un
doigt je pense que tu as un regard mais
non c'est un dauphin dauphin c'est un
site de vente en ligne russe un dauphin
aubry n'a aucune chance en fait mais je
veux tout impôt est complètement fou en
fait
on doit espérer qu'à relief 5e 4 une
petite nuit
les prix là un dauphin c'est un dauphin
quoi quelque part
il joue vraiment ou tempo hissbach
il a vraiment pas compris que c'est dans
leur sentence plus en
face aux portugais
c'est spécial même
deux fines de boutons de manchette
chaise comme la classe wells avec le
bouton de manchette chaise comme est pas
mal
sa méthode ne pas voir une pub alpha
échec surtout oui mais il ya le stand à
wahiba qui à dubaï le paquet à dubaï
pour l'expo universelle
il a été invité bien évidemment pour
représenter
échec way back east en alpha échec
ça avec honneur la rôle diplomatique
aussi le premier temps
qui nous représentons
ce que ba qui va apporter la chine
serait magnifique tanner peau qui
revient je vais tempo et flashy
mais on n'a pas le temps il ya une
soirée qui l'attend c'est vrai qu'à
dubaï à mon avis doit y avoir des belles
soirées ah bah oui
mais
ares 1
ouais c'est ça je faisais pas trop à
propos
baptiste sont plus à l'aise dimanche qui
partent mieux
bon écoute fabes que est-ce que carlson
va l'apprécier ou pas je pense à on dit
que l'ordi donne déjà -0 5
regarde toi sur 6 à 1 contre
- 0
il n'y a pas le feu au lac pour dépôt
mais ça qui joue très vite et que ça ça
peut être
ça peut être un problème
vous 0,22 bien sûr c'est rien c'est pas
ça rien d'affolant
mais c'est vrai que ça passe d'une
position on se dit aucune chance de
perdre pour les peaux et ce qui va
arriver après c'est un peu ce sera
également au pire nul à ce truc là où ça
devient un peu plus pour les noirs et
que on sait déjà que dans le manga plus
de chances de gain pour dépôt est
peut-être un brancard msan donc
forcément la physionomie du match a
évolué et
voilà
pourquoi j'ai ici lors deux deux trois
raisons la première c'est que tu es vite
les maths du couloir dans ta tour des 8
es libre de faire ce qu'elle veut la
puissance et le bouche tu veux prendre
très vite maintenant promis deuxième
truc g6 tu contrôles la case h5 donc tu
vas pouvoir mata torres 6e sens de faire
attaquer donc c'est sympa et puis tu
peux monter ton roi pour la finale faire
des choses comme ça donc c'est multi
usages voilà
c'est pas le coup de l'année mais ça a
l'air d'être le coût proposé fiction
parlée par les moteurs d'analysé
absolument tour tour f6 qui pourrait
sans mettre un coup logique et peut-être
qu'il y ait des 505 c'est vrai ce que je
pense et moi ce que j'avais dans mon
ordi si tu prends elle croit bon là et à
la tomate et si tu prenais ouattara
comme toujours le pion à six qui traîne
donc
moi j'avais ça dans mon rêve je t'aurais
fils qui est né 5 après moi je l'avais
g5 je voulais trouver une donnée g6 g6 a
l'air bien en fait à vrai dire façon tu
veux tous réussissent donc à la rigueur
n'a pas vraiment besoin de le chasser ce
cavalier et voilà donc j'ai 6 permet de
faire ce tour f6 entreprendre de kate
des 5 132 km h cinq ans que tu resteras
un peu je tourne versa
après bon geste si j'imagine re 2
c'est vraiment une partie étrangère je
me répète mais dans les temps le temps
de jeu dans fayyad ya beaucoup de choses
qui font que tu sens que c'est pas une
partie de vraiment très haut niveau un
peu il ya quelque chose de la grande
surface on voudrait
suis en train de me dire sur jugé six
rondes autour efficity cavaliers déjà
bloqué non il ya toujours quatre encore
aujourd'hui les yuccas il a passé
le podcast volée mais oui donc tours 4
il a plus de cases
mais j'espère que tu vas pas faire ça
je suis intéressante d'idrissa vous
pouviez que les pouces ou encore ans
après pas
semble pas mais
c'est un beau bluff ce serait un bluff
extraordinaire mais
là ce sera un bluff extraordinaire
à ce qu'il dit
du rajout gardienne cousinard en plus et
au 60e encore un quart d'heure avec 30
secondes à chaque coup jeu
et g2 pourquoi pas que j'ai enfin sergas
au noir donc j'ai deux pour essayer
d'échanger lecavalier bon
son visage bien sûr à l'auberge et 6 kg
de oui ok donc le bon moi je pense qu'on
peut changer du coup faire qualif 5 ça
attaque la tour hirata plutôt re5 le
plonger ci se protègent le cavalier
c'est aussi tout l'intérêt du pic du
coup v6 quoi bon la donnant là c'est
visuellement on est malin on a pu
tourner plus mauvaise structure les
pièces adhère subjective bon vide
perdant
ce fer marteaux need
et moi ce qui m'inquiète le plus pour
les peaux comme je le disais c'est même
pas la position en soi qui doit être
proclamée mais c'est le fait qu'ils
semblent pas avoir compris
trois petits l'a très bien compris
qu'ils vont se faire mouiller comme ça
en cliquant en blu ray
mais qui avait métaux dans la gestion du
temps ça s'empêche pas dans ce qu'il
fait quand il a fait faux f4 qui n'a pas
du tout compris qu'ils allaient être
moins bien ça c'est sûr
personne ça se voit qu'ils sont bien
trop grave vraiment réfléchir
ok c'est pas évident de faire un truc
mais
simple
jour vient
d'asie fab
tu as envoyé un match à
ouais je sais faire chauffer l'eau et le
hainaut dry
nello dry très important
d'aller dehors non tu as la vraie même
passionnant mais c'est pas sûr fort avec
jia une en effet l'hôte déjà si tu peux
et après je vais essayer de faire non
non il n'y a pas besoin de beaucoup et
après je dirais
petit pub non mais affable qui a fallu à
faire un petit tour qui va un petit peu
voir ce qui se passait
l'aude rihouet haut ouais
il match avec de l'eau dry ça
m'intéresse pas en fait je suis un grand
spécialiste du match aller on va être
sur un match à torréfier
fait c'est un peu ma passion le match a
du coup j'ai testé plein de matches à
plein de recettes différentes je suis un
peu passionné du match à quoi terrible
le match à passionnant ah bah oui c'est
quand même très bon match à
habas oui je me présente quand même un
petit peu niveau matcha
stream je pourrais je vais me préparer
un petit match à l'occasion
bon bah comme le dit stéphane cette
position
ça peut se retrouver à être un peu
dangereux pour les blancs mais il faut
être très précis pour les noix pour
mettre la pression après c'est un petit
peu la marque de fabrique de magnus
carlsen sela qui sent à l'aise
une époque qui semble
pas être au mieux j'ai envie de dire
mentalement dans la partie
il ya un monde une épaule
durant ce contre ucal scène non non
c'est plutôt karl scène qui a qu'un
avantage physique je dirai qui et qui
est plus endurants donc non une épaule
va pas faire ça
daouk nombreux sur scène une très bonne
remarque d'un spectateur ici hystérique
qui me dit qu'il ya pas beaucoup d ombre
sur l'échiquier les pièces font pas du
tout des ombres c'est à dire que
l'échiquier et très éclairé et donc ça
pourrait déconcentrer les joueurs alors
ça c'est possible je peux vous dire par
expérience parce que moi j'étais lumière
bah je vais les allumés et on va voir si
ça dérange fable quand il revient j'ai
des lumières spéciale de studio et je
dois dire que à titre personnel je les
allume de temps en temps mais c'est pas
super agréable de les avoir en face
comme ça et son des lumières vous voyez
qui éclaire bien et qu'il a aussi vont
enlever l'ombre et on l'aimé pas trop
parce qu'on veut pas rester six heures
en face on va voir si ça gênerait fabien
parce que c'est c'est vrai qu'ils
peuvent être dans des conditions pas
tout à fait similaire mais c'est un peu
le même esprit
fab se fait douay
sasaki qui avait pas la doua mais là non
plus ce n'est pas une lampe led c22
grosse lampe qui éclaire bien
fable qui va se faire tester ouais
parce que quand les jeux parti dans une
salle avec un écran un plateau des
chèques dessus alors un plateau non
parce que sinon il pourrait déplacer les
pièces mais souvent il ya un écran et un
genre d'écran de contrôle
papy tu as
non
fabbrica soir avec l'aide de frappes
femme qui ne veut plus revenir
non mais le sait mais en fait on fait un
test comme on a remarqué qu'il ya
beaucoup de lumière sur l'échiquier
parce qu'il ya pas d ombre on veut voir
si les grosses long comme ça te gêne
ouais en fait tu es un peu notre
voilà ça sort ça te gêne
un peu oui tu as à jane way
de tapas tu t'habitues mais deux bases
je préfère ne pas les avoir
déchaîné quoi
gêner
on va s'en remettre non mais j'ai les
enlever c'était pour faire le test mais
ça me gêne ouais j'ai peut-être eu c'est
vrai que c'est très éclairé regarde y'a
pas beaucoup dont peut-être ça les gêne
mais peut-être que les lumières sont
complètement au plafond et tombe à pic
mais ça peut gêner quoi
mais je sais que j'en ris quand j'ai le
temps songé à d'artisans font les petits
ronds la lumière et ça me saoule j'aime
pas du tout quand je tournais des vidéos
là que je devais mettre ce truc ça donne
ça me pique les yeux quoi
il a joué roi et fuite
donc c'est la même idée c'est d'éviter
le match du couloir
cette fois au moins donc faire kg de
trop simplement tous ceux qui avaient
fait ça va aller en fait peut-être
corail fit c'était vraiment pas un super
coup non plus
mais bon qui boit pas je tempo qui
comprend qu'il ya un truc à faire à ce
trio qui continue qu'il s'en fout quoi
g2 est conseillé basse et le fait nous
on le comprend par elie par élimination
comme on a compris que j'ai six idc ce
kg deux cavaliers f 5 tours 5 que le
carnet soit pas en prise comme la page
et six premières pages et six mains tu
comprends que c'est kg de kef 5,5 à vrai
dire là c'est pas faim oui évidemment
d'anjou a axé le coude ordi mais fait on
l'a compris ce qu'on a vu le coût d'ordi
avant et qu'on a compris pourquoi alors
divisé g6 forcément quand il fait page
et si tu comprends ce qu'il faut faire
avec les blancs cher par là que c'est
grâce à leur dit qu'on a compris ça
tempo
et jouer notre jeu ça que ça se passe
moi aussi il manquerait enfin il m'a
fait peur on s'en fout complètement mais
réfléchit il ne clique pas croyez fit
vraiment très grave qu'elle manque de
compréhension
mais en vrai on sent quand même fable
que les joueurs sont dépassés par
l'enjeu c'est pas une partie de
paintball parti c'est pas une belle
partie
ont-ils assez de temps pour bien jouer
diront trop quoi
j trop matin texture intellectualiste
rôle le tournoi au lieu de cliquer quoi
ta logique qu'il faudrait instaurer un
ajournement message à améliorer la
qualité des parties de réinstaurer
l'ajournement puisque les joueurs
pourraient analyser avec l'ordinateur et
donc ils pourraient mieux jouer une
honte c'est vrai que ludwig à ces
raisons là dessus pourrait faire un
ajournement après deux heures de jeu
y at il des joueurs qui utilisent des
méthodes pas très fair play pour
déconcentrer l'adversaire durant un
match un homme exhibé leur odeur
corporelle
savait déjà arrivé mais je sais pas si
c'était volontaire
que les gens me le fasse il y en a qui
sont connus pour être crade mais l'appât
pas mal championne du monde je pense
d'ailleurs que ce serait eux
j'ai pas le mot un motif de disqualifier
un motif de disqualification de puer
quoi
a surtout que ça va à l'eau courante
add on à l'époque scorpio on a des trucs
quand même pour éviter quoi scorpio
après faut le prouver généralement
et g2 attention magnus
partie vraiment étrange infâme je me
répète
mais c'est une partie très décousu ouais
ouais découvrez que vous avez vous eu
l'impression que chaque joueur a son
petit creux son gros creux même ça c'est
quand même fou f4 c'est quand même pas
top
ce qui à fait fou ou trois puits et
non mais je pense qu'il ya une sorte de
chartres à respecter
que tu dois être habiller correctement
et ses
produits dans des open
[Musique]
jaws des mecs qui viennent sans valise
il faudrait une offrande avec les
t-shirts à un moment
il enchaîne deux tours après il faut
tout l'été bon bah c'est toujours le
même t-shirt ouais
enfin c'est fait jacquouille quoi au
fait
c'est comme ça quoi
c'est terrible
mais c'est autorisé enfin ça devrait pas
être
un génie quoi donc
je veux que les girondins un seul arrêt
enfin quoique si tu joues à côté 24
c'est pas mieux ah oui dans le
connaissent pas très bien mon club
c'est vrai c'est le t-shirt bitstream
aurait sans doute cas
de quoi nous faire
ont-ils niveau qui se vaut et y at il
vraiment encore une grande différence
entre ces deux joueurs bon ben magnus
carlsen est un petit peu plus fort mais
à vrai dire si tu jouer contre eux tu me
sentir et parakois c'est acquis mais
la différence est minime mais il se
trouve que
c'est comme si tu poses la question
aux forts et déjà les genres tennis
est donc restée amateurs que tu joues
contre federer nadal djoko nishikori ou
tu veux
ça te faire mal pareil
après qu'un des différences entre eux et
genre tu prends nishikori et
djoko année
en gros il va tout le temps gagner quand
jacques chirac
il gagne 52 points sur 100 un truc comme
ça en fait c'est très peu ces questions
pareil mais en fait vu que tu as des
points plus importants que d'autres et
qui va se concentrer à fond sur ces
points-là est quasiment les prendre à
chaque fois ce soit dans les tie break
où elle devrait écouler balle de break à
défendre sauf un voilà en fait voilà sur
son point jouer ou faire le total des
points dans le match doit vous quasi
pareil quoi mais en fait il ya des
points plus cher que d'autres c'est un
peu pareil et la voilà ta 14 parties en
fait
et sur une partie on peut pas trop de
dire qui va gagner ou quoi parce qu'il
ya une variance 114 partie c'est pour ça
en fait tomber carlson thèmes favoris
parce que c'est un meilleur joueur
d'échecs marginalement même et puis est
repartie plus ça doit parler quoi
mais là oui il a raté il a raté cette
idée
dans la partie et
j'ai envie de dire étonnante de la part
des deux joueurs passe pas grande partie
bon près pas de grande gaffe mais
après le concept quoiqu'il ya 5 qui est
intéressant quand même oui mais j'ai
ressassé à la maison c'est pas vrai
c'est pas tout et c'est pas le niveau de
jeu de la partie mais il vient avec
quelque chose de frais nouveau
d'intéressant qui peut bien
révolutionner une ligne
je connais curie d'une 18,2 au but merci
pour la pour la stat vraiment j'ai fait
un peu de comme je le sentais bien j'ai
pris deux joueurs pourquoi juste et j'ai
cité le pauvre nishikori dans l'histoire
mais qu'il y avait bien un style à sa
frontière
mais bref donc pour en venir là
ouais mais à part ça c'est vrai que j'ai
pas l'ensemble c'était parfait mais
partie dure à comprendre en fait
la position est dur à comprendre il ya
beaucoup de choix il y avait beaucoup de
choix
n'est pas évident de dire clairement ce
qu'il fallait faire
mais c'est ce que c'est possible qu'ils
soient très stressé c'est la seule
explication que je vois à la partie
étrange qu'on est en train de suivre -
probablement qu'ils sont stressés de
façon est de trois ans un autre que je
veux dire c'est que je pense magnus joue
moins bien aux machos bien du monde que
ce qui joue en tournant même ça c'est
évident donc ça peut expliquer aussi et
parce qu'il est stressé moi non donc
c'est s'est une nouvelle fois le stress
mais c'est clair que c'est
pas ça ni penchard les niveaux sont
quand même pris niveler quoi justement
serre que si ma news joue comme ça tout
le match est-ce que c'est pas un 50/50
finalement ce match peut-être mais à un
moment il arrive à se livrer en général
elle va faire qu'ils aient
tant le temps qu'il n'est pas délivrée
qui joue comme ça il n'est pas plus fort
dans les contres car yakine en fait il
s'est déjà bossé des
cdi grand rapide où il a joué quatre
parties en rapide plus impressionnantes
l'une que l'autre tu as l'impression
qu'ils jouer aussi bien voire même mieux
quand longue
il a claqué des parties de folie au
moment le plus important un peu pareil
contre caruana finalement c'est pas tout
à fait le même scénario mais il ya quand
même un peu cette impression ici et là
ça repart ça repart dans le même sens
commun il fait cavalier f5 et forcément
tu sais que j'ai 6 c'était mieux croit
et suite ici c'est sûr que j'ai six
sites
étaient plus forts et dépôts qui al'air
liszt est détendue et maintenant j'ai si
souvent nom qui fait rincer contresens
quoi battu voilà même avec laurent j'ai
eu des sautes au 2 août aurait interdit
kg 2 quand même un coussin bof ça enlève
le qe 2 h 4 était bien placé
il ya la bande en général pas très bien
placé mais là pour le coup dans ces
structures de pions parfait et donc
voilà
bon c'est en art 2 clairement parce
qu'il va falloir défendre le pion
détroit qui attaquait et donc on
centralise le roi des champions quoi de
plus normal quoi
rien
rien de plus normal
un truc re de f 6 tours 4
qui est des six attaques la tour j'ai
fait aujourd'hui a offert aux
epci ce qui est des six tours h4 ça
je vais faire tour g1 en fait moi
j'essaie tu rates 11,5 bon
matin et je me demande même si un jour
tu fais tout re quatre épreuves fillon
prend maintenant ça va être chiante donc
pas trop ça ne va pas être assez
sûrement pour ça qu'il n'a pas fait
on se parle il joue vraiment trop vite
en fait je sais pas franchement ça c'est
une vraie question qu'elle est heureuse
tu peux investir 5 minutes comme pour
décider
par eux dans puis c'est plus logique bah
déjà c'est plus logique donc si tu ne
fais pas voter une bonne raison de le
faire mais c'est étonnant quand même des
poêles a qui jouent tous tempo
ni pourquoi il s'en fout quoi ils
cliquent bon ça va peut-être bon signe
pour lui en fait ce que
mes
pourquoi préférer qu'il y en a eu deux
je peux pas dire vrai le concours de
marche
dit je sais c'est une strate nan mais
c'est bizarre ce qu'il a réfléchi très
longtemps on dit début du milieu de jeu
pour faire vraiment des coups
tu te souviens ou l'autre grand chose et
là tout d'un coup dans des moments hyper
responsable mais l'élan chaîne il
enchaîne tout impôt il joue pas
forcément des grands coups en plus c'est
plus magnus qui a raté une petite
opportunité
mais peut-être qui sans magnus en train
d'imploser je sais pas je sais pas c'est
très étrange
evo6 tour des 1re et dont on n'a pas
parlé on n'a même pas eu le temps de le
voir eux six ils sont en vie c'est bien
placés en un pour attaquer à 6 ans
d'études clous des 3 bon je sais pas
tout ça va mais c'est encore moins
logique mais roy de évidemment c'était
plus logique puisque tu centralise ton
roi et tu protèges ses deux pions et le
cavalier aurait pu revenir en 3 était du
coup k et repart en h4 mais c'est moins
grave enfin ces trucs whaou 2 c'était
vraiment le coût principal
j'écris n'est pas il me fait ça deux
semaines je finis par les en coller une
abbas a peut-être un côté agaçant bon
avec tous blitz et la tronche dans ce
cas c'est vrai qu'on nous dit l'un en
tant au niveau du corps en langage
corporel je suis tout à fait d'accord tu
as un bon c'est complètement renversées
alors qu'au niveau de la position celle
inverse
bon il ya toujours son non plus en fait
ouais les infos publiées quoi et
il essayait de détonner et
[Musique]
après je vais à dire que les noirs sont
pas votre problème intime et en créant
réussite à tous rendez 6
va falloir avancer un parce que les
jours les mêmes chaise
je crois oui
dommage quand meme
je crois que il ya trois ans il y en
avait un qui avait une chaise blanche et
l'autre une chaise noire
mais quand même chaise verte le fauteuil
c'est bien
c'est l'impression qui se passe pas
grand chose comme dans cette partie
même si à ce tube plus avec magnus et
réussit à visser mais
n'aurait pu être
complètement désemparé pour pour les
peaux si j'avais un peu continuer sur
sur sur la voie qu'ils avaient tracé
mais finalement il y aura peu
d'enseignements à tirer de cette partie
si on en reste là le clic ça a cliqué
aucun des deux joueurs n'a vraiment été
impressionnants ils ont tous les deux eu
leur période
homme et je suis pas sûr ça se finir si
vite ce vin et peut être même essayé de
sites arrivent à un moment à faire chez
page et j'imagine tour 4b
4t change tant pis on doublait
bajard tête et a une petite idée qu avec
les blancs tu te dis si j'allais faire
ça s'est passé la
marche bien on va y arriver
mais
pourquoi
tu peux continuer à cliquer pendant un
petit moment quoi c'était dépôt
tu peux
est ce que tu penses qu'il va cliquer
rapidement là non il s'est un peu posé
il semble sûre baissier de faire ce
petit match si je peux aller
va donc des pages de pub peut-être
pourtant
bon bah oui
bon
comme ça le match ça va arriver on va
être bien
tu connais beaucoup en gros plan qui
réfléchit
non pas de la souris
très compliqué
les flèches
et on va voir s'ils comptent nous jouer
dépôt est bon évidemment c'est difficile
de trouver comment vraiment avancer avec
les blancs qu'on lit tout à l'heure de
ce club en open structure jenny on n'a
pas les pièces forcément
hyper harmonieuse
mais un bon ok
toujours un avion et au cavalier kg 7 du
coup je vais pas en magnus donc le
dernier coup en date je suis l'homme
quelque est reparti
pourquoi peut-être pour venir son âge 5
sont aussi se recycler peut-être pour
venir vérifie 4 où ça permettrait à la
fois mettre une pression sur détroit est
sûre et sur age 3 donc j'imagine c'est
son idée
voilà après que les blancs bon retour
remettre la tour en quatre pour défendre
sa
mai mais bon c'est dur avec les blancs à
la fois on chez si plan-là des noirs
denses et d'autres thèmes et
d'avoir ses pages et sera bien un petit
coup de tours là
disons que magnus en mains de cavalier
là où là quelque part là et pourquoi pas
ça est-ce que ça on peut faire très le
plan j'aimerais mettre en place pour les
blancs
donc je vous disais en fait pourquoi je
fais cette série de coups c'est le côté
blanc je suis très heureux si je fais
disparaître ce pion contre suis là parce
que des pions doublé qui me sert pas à
grand chose en enlevant pioncer 5 que je
fais qui nous est ici ça devrait avions
passé et s'améliorait ma structure après
évidemment tour quatre peut-être que les
noirs peut faire autre chose que
quelques si c'était un des coûts
auxquels on pouvait penser mais
déjà bondi de 13,5 qui est une option
qui chasse la tour offre croit le monde
la 4e rangée
quoi le mandat soit 5,65 plus d'armée
c'est une option quand même pour les
noirs pour lutter contre ce genre
d'idées
mais bon ça serait
peut-être du cou qui avait lié la
500 il faut la rebouché
al aoula et le cavaly vient et
finalement
ce qu'arrive en effet mettre ces petites
améliorations pour les morts dont je
suis pas sur mon cou de taureau 4 soit 6
euros pour les blancs ça donne le temps
de tout mettre en place
ouais
ouais du coup qu'il faut chercher autre
chose
au volant dit il propose f 4 pour les
blancs pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pas trop ce
pur talent ça ne venait pas forcément
mais bon entre ma position on peut
comprendre il veut faire f 4 grands
sécurité pour comme moi c'est qu'il s'en
aille il a f5 et ont déjà laissé voir sa
déception doublé et d'une de ses
faiblesses pourquoi pas après j'avais
bien le garder là a priori juste parce
que je me dis qu'elle cavaliers il les
défend et et ça va pas si mal
mais il faut mettre un coup pourquoi pas
fier à troquer re 2 j'imagine c'est une
case quand même bien mais justement se
met en position d'être en échec sur kf4
donc on n'est pas ravi ravi
est
bon tout ça pour dire que c'est pas si
évident entre la cotisation blanche
parce que les pauvres
j'ai pas leur enlever son drapeau russe
donc bel fc match amical non avec pas du
tout non mais c'est hyper important en
fait on a changé le monde et chaque
parent s'est passé vous rendez compte
mais
ses rangs un truc dans l'histoire
c'est plus important que
tout ce qu'on peut voir d'autres comme
tournent en général
même pendant les olympiades qui sont un
beau tournoi ou davis kenzy
candidat candidat c'est génial déjà est
en fait le but des candidats c'est juste
de se qualifier à ce à quoi donc déjà
c'est très dur des candidats mais ça
donne juste le droit d'être là assis à
cette table dans lequel on est là tu
peux pas être là on dirait un ballet que
j'ai pas mon drapeau que j'ai mon
drapeau à sa team pata c'est trop
important et c'est un moment qui peut
être unique dans ma carrière une chance
qu'on n'a pas tous les jours enfin le
plein de joueurs
je sais pas il ya des joueurs qui n'ont
jamais joué deux matches du championnat
du monde
dit qu'ils étaient très forts
chance en des joueurs contemporain
pourrait parler de parent rognant par
exemple
ils vont de choc alors mon chèque et la
coupe du monde fis de 2002 mais je
considère pas ça comme des chemins du
championnat du monde
oui des jours comme ça dans le passé on
peut penser intéresse on peut penser
tu sais pas plein de mecs quoi
et on progresse c'est pas mal comme
exemple
et donc
donc voilà on né peut pas être dans dix
ans je m'en fiche c'est qui fait que
c'est hyper important et voilà
alors valable qui paraître désacraliser
le titre de champion du monde pendant
plus intéressant on du public et aussi
pour faire participer le champion du
monde au temps des candidats qu'en
penses tu c'est une option en fait un
style ont pour l'instant ça qui est cool
et ont sacralisé comme je vous disais
même pour moi et lin donc
après de le rendre différents ou de
faire participer le chemin du monde
autour des candidats ça peut être
intéressant parce que effectivement
finalement le tournoi le plus
intéressant à suivre je préfère sur
votre toit des candidats
parce qu'il est toujours de l'enjeu il
se passe des choses c'est hyper bien
pour moi le meilleur tournoi que ce soit
suivre a commenté
mais malheureusement entre guillemets ça
boit très intéressant ça donne rien
comme titre ça donne juste le droit de
juste ce match ont peut-être que ça
devienne le tournoi ultime comme si le
plus intéressant une fois pourquoi pas
mais après du coup
du coup c'est quoi le champion du monde
ce serait le vainqueur du jour un des
candidats et il serait grave qualifie
pour le candidat de la fois prochaine et
que c'est un à un ils avaient tous les
quatre du coup le couple envisageait
ce qu'on faisait la turbine est setec
élèves cinq bons qui est pas forcément
dire avec 5 mais se trouvait pour
s'adapter pour un arbre sinon b4 comme
une menace pour les blancs
bref je vais finir sur ce que je raconte
dont peut-être tu peux prendre le
champion du monde qui
qui qui qui firent le candidat prêt et
que ce soit ça le format où on pourra
penser à autre chose c'est que tu gardes
disons le vainqueur de ce match mais
qu'après de fer droit des candidats les
trois premiers sont qualifiés et que tu
pars en demi finale et que le champion
du monde je compte le troisième pour les
deuxièmes dans l'autre demi finale et
que tu te fais une grosse phase comme ça
je sais pas il ya peut-être des choses
possibles je sais pas mais en tout cas à
l'heure actuelle comme le format et sais
pas si c'est mieux ou pas de changer
c'est un beau symbole truc ce truc de
ses deux champions du monde
je ne peux pas être là en mode
je la prends la légère quoi
datant de 1900 et nos pratiques sa
demande bien trop en termes de pertes
non c'est possible enfin perso n'a
jamais été fait mais karl ce n était pas
si loin il était au delà de 1881 non
mais
franchement partie non ouais ouais bon
après c'est dans le monde la partie déjà
grâce à moi de jouer je me lève pas si
j'ai plus trop de temps j'essaie de pas
trop mauvais mais des fois ça fait du
bien juste de se dégourdir les jambes de
souffler un peu mais espère même quand
tu marques tu penses à la partie
énormément est pas là de marché à faire
n'importe quoi c'est devrait se
concentrer mais juste ça décontract un
peu
d'activité physique qui permet de bien
revenir des fois tu m'aimes tu chopes
des idées pendant une balade et
peut-être je peux faire ça un truc tu
avais pas pensé dans l'échiquier donc
je suis dit qu'il adore lui le format
ben ouais non mais il est pas mal le
formant sans
que je pense à karlsson barbeau deux
monstres du jeu boyle est
assez haut placées quoi
c'est toujours dur de comparer les
époques mais
c'est peut-être le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire déjà et s'il ne l'est pas il
est dans le trio tu peux le mettre avec
des caisses paraphé fischer
10 ans à partir ou y aura qui déjà
peut-être des mecs on connaît pas encore
et puis carl scène il n'aura que
quarante ans encore justin envie quoi
donc donc tous les joueurs qu'on voit là
ils seront pas forcément finie pour
autant
viru qu'est ce qui sera dans 10 ans bon
c'est pas non plus rabat qui n'ont sur à
bakchich bajramaj rcgt objet d'un peu me
dépêcher parce que j'entendais des
conversations même si le blizzard il se
parait qu'il venait qui venait de ce
côté de la pièce sa cité les meilleurs
joueurs du monde en disant ça ne parlait
pas de pas qui est quand même embêtant
fab
a dans dix ans c'est trop dur je veux
vous dire non et je sais pas firent où
il sera dans dix ans donc tout ce qu'il
aura été les échecs ouais ouais ingère
tu peux pas savoir voilà ce qu'il dit là
pas trop envie d'arrêter
passionne bien mais
mais mais on en fait commencé à la
chanson florent pagny sort et un jour
une femme et ça va dans la vôtre
florent pagny de quoi enfin voila il pas
qui mais on va prendre a cliqué tout
cinq mois dans cette partie
bas il ajoute hors castes être pas le
meilleur 5 s'adonner oui j'ai entendu
ses membres ce que je regarde un peu à
la partie comme objet match elle vise en
fait à f/5 intéressant pour les noirs
envie de le faire et il lui a donné sur
un plateau d'argent
c'est vraiment une partie 20e j ai
repensé entendent en préparant le match
à savoir une partie bizarre
les
dmc ce critère fap il ya une grosse en
huit ans sort une partie mais
non mais c'est le cas mais c'est
intéressant de voir que même à ce niveau
ils sont pas infaillibles infaillible et
et que la pression je pèse on voit avec
n'est pour regard sur la cam il est il
ya des mécontents
la partie est très étrange
même une bonne nouvelle ce sont huit
coups sûrs prendre une heure pour
annoncer de répulsion et à 38 il
comprend plus rien non en fait je pense
que
passer la partie incompréhensive
vraiment en fait
peut être qu'ils jouent pour bien
je peux pas de bien
je reproduis même pas trop ce
mai mais c'est bizarre maintien de fer
qui a eu un chi chi
le toit pudeur leurs 11 mai
c'était très bien
c'est étrange salvat pourrait nous
éclairer ici moi je pense à partir en
petit slip
non là on a
une partie étrange
je pense qu'on pouvait s'arrêter sur
chaque coup et se demandaient ce n'est
pas mieux à faire un problème en
le tapant un coup sur deux qui auraient
pu être mieux jouer
c'est beaucoup à ce niveau
en saveurs non mais surtout les
contresens et un peu comme lecavalier
tout à l'heure quand le cavalier partie
en bep cap puis ans et 6 puis 7 plateaux
si lecavalier ogier 2e à g 2 1 il a
quand même beaucoup de manoeuvres qui
sont à contresens qui rare à ce niveau
là à l'ordre erwin demande
si on peut regarder le pion des 3 et 4 4
mais je vais monter tours 4 je pense
qu'on le récupère en fait
tu peux faire qu'il ferait pas tout
reprendre si ce n'est presque plus je
suis forte peut-être
donc au fait tu ne peux pas
c'est une position immobile et c'est
pour ça
séparément immobile comme position et
chose à faire quand même
il ya des manoeuvres il ya des choses
mais
non mais c'est vraiment long jeu a
dépassé le jeu en fait c'est vraiment ce
qu'elle ce cas de figure
on l'a dit en
pré live que les premières parties d'un
même championnat du monde était parfois
un peu étrange et celle ci déroge pas à
la règle
ouais souffert mais
ils ont passé beaucoup de temps à se
préparer pour ce match et ils ont un peu
de mal à rentrer dedans
mais ça aussi ce que ça représente
non clairement clairement infâme
c'est pas une partie emballante en tout
cas non à suivre aux mêmes dates avons
une belle finale un bon truc un moment
je ne sais pas ah oui ça peut elle peut
le devenir peut le devenir mais pour
l'instant
tibet 4 pour pour cette affiche les
quatre c'est pas un coup que je la joue
c'est aussi pour ça qu
il est champion du monde c'est peut-être
enfin un bon coup dans cette partie
euros on va de l'idée
ok mouvement du bien ces trois pour se
gagner les caisses des cadres est
autrement de pouvoir échanger est tombé
huit il finalement elle est appuyé sur
b3
plutôt que d'être rock était facile à
défendre avec le taureau 3 l'heureuse
possible et c'est vrai que c'est là que
tu regrettes parce que tu aurais pas
perdu les deux temps torriero de roi des
deux races et de noms mais je ne peux
pas trop comprendre qu'il est enfin la
zone quand ça a été je ne comprenais pas
et ce qui se passe saverne nous donne
une raison bien
dur à expliquer en pâtit a priori mal
joué
c'est plus qu'à priori
car en fait tu veux des cas et la tour
peut-être même je tombe pour wife cette
tourbe et six mois tu aimes ça fait des
deux côtés for
fair tour b6 tour des six pour couvrir
tu va taper partout
il est bon ce match je n'ai pas encore
mais je souffre le monstre tus ou flotte
ouais
il a l'air magnifique mais du bon du
très bon
magnifique
si je mets un petit peu moins daudrich
avant de danser
pourquoi lui semblait plus de densité
après c'est vrai que l'année peau je le
trouve vraiment négligent dans sa mère
de ce lever de repartir de paresthésie
fin magnus tu sens qu'il a envie de la
gagner n'est pas
parce qu'il est
le message qu'il envoie ses je vais
faire du lancy flottant français pas de
message qu'il envoie mais en fait ça va
paître en sifflotant du tout là
il ya avantage magnus là-bas peut-être
pas vraiment en réalité memphis a
annoncé par l'ordinateur mais le truc
c'est que le scénario de la partie et
étrangers on a l'impression que c'est
plus snif peau qui perd les pédales fin
magnus et les a un peu perdu plus tôt
mais là on a l'impression que c'est
quand même une époque hyper complètement
les pédales
il est clair qu'un bon jeu offre encore
là nul année peau ça sans aucun doute un
oui une chanson non plus
mais bon
on dit après n'ai pas toujours eu ce
côté nonchalant
oui mais il n'a pas forcément lieu en
début de partie
nul avait blanc c'est pas terrible je te
rassure je vous avais un droit de se
sont devrait y en avoir beaucoup après
tu es toujours mécontents pressé mais
tu peux gagner un match championnat du
monde en 6 nuls enfin sept nuls en sept
parties avec les blancs ah bah oui comme
celle de derrière match n'a pas gagné
une seule partie elle était là il a
gagné le match championnat du monde non
mais nul étant le résultat comme le plus
probable
impressions après un mois de cire rouge
à m'apprécier rouge à ce n'était pas la
même
c'était pas la même position quand même
eu l'occasion
je comprends vos frais emballé mais
c'était pas cap seine en face quoi
et pourquoi jouer fin quand il a joué
compte mvl il fait un maxime avec les
north a fait nul facile contre ali reza
demande à regagner la non contre grimal
emma mais c'est juste parce que c'est
par équipes mais sinon c'est turbo droid
hydrique look en quinze coups deux
mamediarov en quinze coups après vont
faire gagner oui non mais et après ça
n'est pas son maître d'avoir cartouches
et tous les mecs moins fort bien c'est
passionnant mais c'est pas la même
position se prennent aux adversaires en
fait donc c'est pas pareil en fait tu
peux pas un mais c'est comme si tu as un
gars qui bat au tennis entre top 70 top
100 20 mondial 6-1 6-1 tous les matches
bon c'est du rhin et peut-être même fait
d août joe cole ferais pas mais c'est
pas du tout pareil de cartonner 6 1 6 1
tapez 80 monde ou sans monde d'aller
jouer après le masters c'est pas les
mêmes joueurs en face quoi
donc bon mois qu'en fait forcément c'est
plus le jeu contre un joueur plus fort
qu'un autre qui cherche à gagner et
c'est moins bien préparés et donc c'est
moins solide et ça donne d'autres dodge
en deux parties quoi
pourtant ça joue mieux
c'est plus ouvert
et puis c'est pas le même enjeu au-delà
de ça oui je veux dire par là que
l'aller les joueurs
à force de ne pas vouloir commettre
d'erreurs parfois on en fait c'était
pour ça aussi qu'on avait sorti la vidéo
de la partie de botanique bronstein
votre juste avant le match parce que ça
illustrait bien ce qui peut arriver
quand on veut ne pas quand on veut ne
pas jouer en fait
en sorte de citations dont on prend des
risques on peut perdre mais qui n'en
prend pas pour toujours pas comment les
dix exactement c'est un peu mieux dit
que ce que je viens de faire mais
c'était seul sens
et en russe on dit celui qui prend des
risques boit du champagne ou l'un vers
celui qui ne prend pas de risques ne
bois pas de champagne mais c'est le même
c'est la même idée
au bout du champomy quoi
encore position pouce pour n'est pomey
wayne et pau il déçoit quand même un
petit peu
non mais là sa dernière série de quoi
pas été terrible à dire car je comprends
pas si longtemps plus on peut repasser
on peut repasser toute la partie en vrai
vous la voyez en bas à droite de votre
écran qui défilent cet espagnol
et on va avoir le droit à une anti
marshall le h3 et cavaliers à 5 entre
guillemets la nouveauté à haut niveau
donc on va rentrer dans une variante
plus ou moins forcé qui était préparé
par les deux joueurs n'y a pas eu de
surprise n'est peau qui connaissait donc
on va voir cette finale qui va
apparaître à l'écran où les noirs ont
assez de contre jeu pour pour l'heure -
mais on va voir ici voilà un plan un peu
bizarre et kébé 4 qui part vous allez
voir que le cavalier va revenir ans et 6
puis partir en hausse est finalement le
fou 3 x 4 qui était quand même très
laborieux aussi et qui va donner
une chance aux noirs de trouver du jeu
comme on le voit là avec leurs cavaliers
qui vient puis les blancs vont réussir à
se réorganiser les noirs vont taper ici
sur le pion detroit et les blancs vont
faire cavalier loin pour le défendre
puis revenir plus tard avec leurs
cavaliers en g2 donc c'est là encore des
décrets motion qui vont pas du tout
ensemble près mon choix
donc il ya eu il ya eu dans cette partie
plusieurs séries de coups qui le
foudroie fouet f4 qui a et b 4 et 6 qui
a valu aux sept cavaliers eu un cavalier
g2
g3 trois séquences de coûts
fab qui semble complètement incohérente
car après ils les ont joué parce qu'ils
n'ont pas trouvé mieux mais généralement
en partie on sait très bien quand on
joue que si on fait ça ça va pas aller
par expérience c'est très rare que ce
soit des coûts qui fonctionne
on demande d'être plus dynamique alors
après si ce type de position marche bien
pour karl scène j'ai bien peur à
beaucoup
de buts c'est pas toi respecte assez
d'être champion du monde a en club
le but comme tu le dis c'est de gagner
le titre au bout manu ci fait le
spectacle dans les tournois généralement
maintenant il ya une beaucoup de parties
ouais là clairement l'objectif c'est
simplement de gagner un match de
championnat du monde du jeu d'échecs
mais
ça ne favorise cette partie je pense
de manière très étonnante on
n'aurait pas on n'aurait pas imaginé
tourné il ya encore une heure de ça
cette partie
mais là elle commence elle commence à
tourner et à force de tourner la roue
tourne tourne ont cessé il est pas très
inquiète
car
000 mais c'est sûr que c'est 0-0 mais en
fait
ça va pas être zéro zéro pendant
longtemps ci n'est pour continuer à
faire du contresens
ça existait des championnats du monde et
champion du monde qui donnait plein de
spectacles et de panache
kasparov déjà c'est quand même assez
spectaculaire même si contre karpov sa
accouché de beaucoup de nuls mais
c'était
le scénario qu'a voulu ça
enfin je veux dire c'étaient d'autres
règles en fait le premier 6 victoires et
en fait karpov a vite eu mené 5-0 quoi
après une petite quinzaine de partis et
d'ong bak a soif savaient que s'ils
perdaient une de plus c'est déjà fini
donc c'est bien blindé moi me prendre un
risque qui n'a jamais perdu une fois 5 1
5 2 5 3
beaucoup de nuls et puis puis match
arrêté mais après l'autre match ça
fighter et d'ailleurs même 84 je crois
que les premières rondes c'était des
west indienne très chaude peut-être la
première partie du match mais non
tu échoues quoi
après dans les granges grand champion du
monde attaque on pense évidemment tout
ça talent
dix employés nuit heure
allègrement il eut à l'équipe aussi dans
les dents les joueurs d'un rack pour
fisher matcher oui
bien évidemment
non il ya eu des grands joueurs d'attac
champion du monde après les époques les
époques anciennes capablanca tout ça
c'était le jeu d'échecs était quand même
bien différent ouais je ne vois rien
proches james tanis qu'un joueur plutôt
positionnelle risque d'attaqué si fait
ouais mais là avant avant cette attaque
est tellement plus globalement
aujourd'hui ça aurait été un joueur
d'attac
justic clikeco afin de positionner ses
jeux peu un peu mieux attaquer ton roi
maintenant je vais te mater regarde
le droit de rennes on en sait contresens
total
ça commence à m'inquiéter pour pour yann
trop de contresens dans cette partie bon
c'est un coût qui semble jouable le
deuxième c'était pas le top choix c'est
h4 dans le monde
je peux comprendre mais du coup pourquoi
pas refaire de il ya quatre coups c'est
ce que j'allais dire en fait c'est pas
le coup en soit maintenant qui me choque
mais c'est la tis et là c'est vraiment
une question de direction
mes pensées de chat l'expression russe
il faut justifier técou la justifie
après c'est pas mal de pas trop vouloir
justifier parfois mais là tu sens quand
même que c'est too much
et magnus qui a répondu tempo tourbe et
8,1 c'est bien joué de la part de deux
magnus qui essaye d'y mettre la tête
sous l'eau
l'esclavagé des grands virois chou en
championnat du monde jeune mon
pote sur 1000 pourcentage de faire ça
mais quand ils pensent capable en cas
les kin impossible le nom mais il
faisait gris combi dam d'ailleurs with
bourse a eu une française d'ailleurs et
avant les matchs de l'as caire tout sauf
téhini du carter qu'il aurait pu envoyer
même contre stanic mais je crois pas
qu'il ait fait j'ai pas que ça à jouer
des cartes à l'époque aussi bon il ya
des petites espagnols les petites
bas-rhinoise déjà mais
ça doit être du carter qui jouait des
cas troublants
steijns qui joue à 4
alors que ce qu'il a pu
bonne surprise comme
quoi
ce que j'ai déjà joué avec un échiquier
homologué world championship ouais
j'ai déjà eu cet échec heures entre les
mains
a pas celui-là a précisément mais j'ai
eu celui du match à nantes carte scène
entre des mains le vrai nom de le fondre
aussi ou non
en fait la demande carl scène c'est
pendant que je travaillais à la fidh
c'est là que les le petit rond blanc
petit rond devrait donc sauf que j'étais
vraiment reçu j'ai vraiment touché c'est
juste qu'ils tuent les invalides validé
way en amont du match
chercheuse est touchée avant bon eux
mêmes avant les joueurs wii
en pions il va les cours le colmater les
brèches ou clermont vern hull
ça doit suffire regard il a juste un
petit regard donc l'idée en fait c'est
sûr pions prend si on prend tout reprend
passé de suspense n'a pas le temps en
temps le 6e tour aussi sont
tombés d'euros
et ça va tu touches la tour donc vu que
jean retrouver trois russes et 2 il peut
pas doubler tour il va devoir partir
et normalement tu dis que tu dois pour
tenir
mettez un peu moins bien même ça doit
tenir oui
mais bon personne ne peut te longtemps
est-ce que tu retrouves existera tour à
deux à chaque fois qu'un homme
est tombé à une finale c'est pas ton cas
les doigts du pain toi là même avec le
cavalier en d2 tu payes ces cas tu
serais même bien ton car elle est trop
mal à l'état tu pourras faire tour e 5
qui a valu au 3 quai et ses quatre
enfants dans 17 villes travaillent chez
tattoo re es tu peut couvrir ici
à vrai dire ici tour un singe amiens
pour cb six tours à
2,10 à moi je suis accueilli six
accueils c4
j'aurais très confiante pas perdre ça
mais leur 10ème pas
un machin comme c'est bon t'as l'autre
truc tu vas en revenir au f4 saab est en
fait il veut te veux tu gagnes h et
envoyer de l'autre côté après ouais
c'est peut-être dur en cassage où il ya
et puis on prend ces 3 3 français 3 ça
paraît impossible un
nom ça la structure des pions serait
trop détruites
il va regretter de ne pas avoir suivi
nostra bla du ce n'est pas omis achi
ouais puis vont même aux autres qui est
gênant et aurait une écossaise
au moins ils auraient une partie
d'échecs
le match d'ouverture qui ne tient pas
toutes ses promesses
aussi brasser deux solides pour partir
je suis pas tombé sa tombe et 8 dans
l'aveu quoi il se relève ça pour moi ça
traduit la nervosité de se lever comme
ça à ce moment là du match
tu sais que ça va jouer tempo t'as pas
obligé d'aller courir non
plus trois coups jusqu'au 40e
certes leurs cadres en
ce2 génitales miens
moi je te sens tu es sur un autre
vocabulaire au j'ai senti la glissade oh
non il y aura peu de bus à deux jours de
vent étaient là mais
tu la pensée pour entendre ce que je
pense c'est autre chose on a on a
entendu ce que tu penses aimons fab
il se levait très souvent à partie
importante des candidats compteraient
belle oui mais sa santé qu'il était très
stressé il va pas pouvoir être aussi
stressé que ça pendant deux semaines
d'affilée ah non sinon il va juste pété
un plomb et
ça se traduira par une gaffe un jour ou
l'autre c'est à dire contre ils veulent
je trouve pas que c'est une partie dans
pierrefonds n'y croyais à quoi mais bon
il a su serrer le jeu pour les affaires
nul
il n'a pas du tout mis en danger enfin
c'était pas son butin mais
quitte à perdre le match il veut gagner
celui de la marche ça c'est sûr pour ça
il prend une belle marge de son équipe
on nous dit d'acea c'est au
passé 4 on ferait j'imagine
il faudra voir comment ça se passera
demain mais s'il est aussi stressé que
ça demain c'est ça tu peux pas en fait
nan
mais faut descendre un petit peu
bande la tisane toussaint
[Musique]
et au nom et au nom
magnus fidèle à lui-même quand même
en hiver il de faire souffrir longtemps
pour s'accuser
du faux son petit match à l'epo
on peut changer de tramway c'est une
bonne idée on va retourner jamais
remettre les calmes des joueurs là la 3
et la 5 elles sont pas mal à l'ecam
couples ont des gros plans et surtout
que tu as toujours un 10 enfin toujours
un des deux joueurs tu as souvent dépôts
qui se lève donc là tu as vraiment
l'impression d'être immergé sur
l'échiquier un
fossé comme ça face à carl scène reste
vraiment cette impression elle est bien
placée cette caméra et c'est vrai que la
qualité de l'image est quand même assez
top
ça change
des caméras diop
mais bon après un grand merci une
nouvelle fois je le répète mais à samo
sans qui on n'aurait pas pu voir les
caméras c'était quand même sympa de sa
part de les partager un peu mieux ils
ont fait du mieux qu'ils pouvaient et
c'est vrai que
si tous les tournois nous donner les
caméras comme ça enfin petit à petit tu
as he can départ en avant dans la bonne
direction tu vas tu sens des mecs bien
intentionnés qui veulent dans le solaire
développé les échecs ça fait plaisir ça
change quoi sont restés petit faux
demande qui serait réceptifs à des
feedback sur les feedback sur les sur
les cadences et c'est pour faire évoluer
le truc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup et ça fait plaisir de voir les
organisateurs slovène aller coûte quoi
monstre mais un et ce qu'ils ont fait
de sensationnel ils veulent faire
avancer les échecs quoi tu joues enfin
c'est rare d'avoir des gens qui veulent
faire avancer les échecs bon sens dans
le bon sens serait ok pour vrai ou quoi
ça fait ça fait très plaisir
donc tour bessède jouer et donc moi
j'étais surtout re lors des dix tours 5
peut-être pas si facile encore de faire
nul
banon
et c'est pas fait je 4 par exemple si en
un qui sera traînée pourquoi
là puisque tu as moi le truc que
j'aurais jouer instinctivement répliqué
c4 quoi j'avais l'impression que je
faisais des nuits tranquilles et l'ordi
données -
donc ça veut dire que c'est pas si
simple 1 h 4 c'est tellement responsable
nouvelles soit parce que j'en pense je
peux être sûr c'est bien que
je ne raconte ceci vas-y
-0 19
h pas si mal à tenir parce que tu as le
plan aussi droite c'est un pion âge qui
peut partir en orbite à ça aussi mais à
un moment donné tu peux couper le jeu en
deux avec les vins à retaper la taper là
c'est réellement dangereux parce qu'il
rend à agen qui serait bien en vrai une
petit à petit que tu restes sur le
fronton point de six mois yves bertucci
tu vas commencer par tomber 6 pour le
monde
non mais je sais bien pas tout mais je
le prends de mèze c'est pas si simple à
mettre en place en fait tant qu'à
l'étranger 2
après tu peux aussi temporisé de m afp
six pour le rouge
c'est quand même pas mal même si sainté
bourrin
je voudrais tourbe et istres à temps
mais si c'est sûr il va faire tour à
deux du plus gros savon c'est un peu le
pion aux envies ou de tuer je ferai plus
tard
c'est marrant parce que tu disais tu
allais un truc très très vrai là en
avant match tu as dit ciné pause
retrouve sous pression il jouera vite
parce que il reprendra ses mauvaises
habitudes sous stress c'est tellement ce
qui est en train de se passer
à une très bonne analyse là dessus en
avant match
solide fort stress je les dépôts me mets
ta ville a réussi à se contrôler et puis
il explose complètement mais c'est
intéressant parce que tu l'as bien
pressenti ça
j'en suis
faby slave 4 chefs il a toujours su
nostra fabius
sans lui
st laurent c'est ça
ces polars sont qu'au milieu du match il
a reçu une nouvelle il a un truc
d'affaires non mais c'est tellement ça
s'est il a changé d'attitude qu'on a un
truc qui c'est qui s'est cassé quoi
faut-il à des phosphates et goûter ouais
j'ai pu énerver houphouet et il ya un
truc qui va pas claire mais cette poule
comme ces secours il n'arrive pas à se
calmer et carlson il le sent en phase et
bonbons il fait pas une grande partie un
nom mais bon il est là quoi
il me fait penser à un pipo inzaghi
d'accueil manquent
dans son dos il tranquille il n'attend
voir ici peuvent écouter un truc ouais
c'est ça ouais je peux web et qui s'est
enfui ans pas rare non plus mais mon
rêve cette clique
bon là on est déjà au 38ème courant les
amis les joueurs ont encore
largement assez de temps pour récupérer
une heure souvent on récupère au 40e
donc pas d'inquiétude sur les ponts du
il doit avoir à peu près un quart
d'heure chacun à quelque chose près
les deux joueurs ont largement le temps
de jouer deux coups et va enfin pouvoir
souffler après récupérer une petite
heure
alors c'est pas sûr qu'ils aient une
vraie temporisation avec avec cette
heure de rage ou parce que nés pause
j'ai l'impression qu'il est pas là pour
temporiser
mais
rien encore envoyé
lille a pour thème paurise et
j'ai pas compris pourquoi pas commencer
par tour b6 que là ils auraient tourbe
et de en fait ouais ouais natura 2000
énigmes à la sueur tomber si sa tête or
ben ouais ouais je sais pas si tu as
envie de jouer cette finale de cheveux
avec
qui
semble si tu dois prendre faire 3-2 non
non bien des changements faisant un truc
intéressant de chacun des 4 e ben
à se regarder quand même
oui bon ça marche pas du tout jamais au
coude avant c'était important dr entre
les deux victoires c'est les autres
pièces du roi y avait la fourchette mais
après la sae marché avait francs l'air
ah bah oui mais les fautes directes mais
bon c'est vrai que c'est un coût qui
peut marcher c'est un truc quand tu
joues tempo que tu peux complètement
vapeur alors avoir 10 à 5 qui se font
une idée pourquoi way des quatre marchés
c'est
ce que québec à trois des onze qui ont
dit qu'ils fourchette mais non parce
qu'ils attendaient un surplus on prend
dix décès puis on prend
hélas ça pénètre au tour elle revient
machin c'est pareil quoi
donc voila mais en fait à 5g des
questions sais pas s'il est probable ou
pas ce qui est peu probable mais est-ce
qu'on est si noir d'avancé
fait mal en fait le truc qui faisait ça
il te faire quatre premiers il a ravi
pourquoi pas en photo sans faire de
ravir aime ce que tu me quand même à
trois tours b deux temps mais
ça ne fait quand même pas loin de gain
d'un vrai que ça avance en force en
mêlée all black j'ai pas le temps de
troquer ses quatre heures moi c'est ce
que j'ai tout le temps pensé mais en
fait il s'en fout
moi j'ai fait moi je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ça en vrai
alors pourquoi là je suis mal avec les
bleus en fait celui-ci de ce fait ça
dormez au québec ne change pas c'est
peut-être plus con quand même hein mais
quoi qu'il en soit a quand même
l'impression d'avoir réussi un truc avec
les plantes à bloquer la casse v2 a
bloqué le pion à et ut libérer les tours
enfin le blizzard a publié le roi oui
mais bon t'as un frisson qu'arturo 5
non musulmans visuellement pourquoi tu
as un problème photo kc khatib l'autre
enfin il blanc de toul un bain froid tu
es mal même j'ai même du mal à
comprendre même maintenant je dis non 6
3 5 camions je fais tour
5-6 ans je fais toi
fourchette l'autoroute rendu contre
104,3
mais c'est fou ce truc que t'as pas
l'impression que ce soit si grave et
puis quatre coups après ses pertes
laurent hagist y est paisible par un
échec à tout moment il va bouffer le
pion et tu te fais défoncer
mais à vrai dire si magnus il avait
trouvé ça il aurait peut-être gagné très
facilement
non mais c'est vraiment pas une grande
partie je me répète mais il ya quand
même beaucoup d'opportunités de coups
ratés mais genre tout le temps
ma nièce a raté une grosse chance mais
j'ai l'impression à ce que le truc de m
enfin le truc c'est que la défense
convient de montrer c'est la défense
humaine et c'est en gros ce soit cher
que tout le monde ait fait ce match et
et sinon c'est pas évident tu souffres
est bon
pour il joue l'autre plan une avance
tranquillou
à un moment il va quand même se crée un
pur âge pas ses promoteurs après c'est
bien joué aussi mais bon un problème le
pion à l'afrique c'est peut-être
haletante qui a eu trois cas y ckt tu
touches impasse
c'est hyper dur à trouver le plan
justement parce que visuellement ça a
l'air de tenir pour les blancs ouais
mais le truc c'est quand tu cumules
tous les plans ratés
depuis tout à l'heure un moment donné on
va dans sa tante se trouve un truc
durant jours c'est ça ça va être pour le
moment on va exagère un peu mais si on a
la même prêt parce que tu as
l'impression que tu m'aies fab libye et
caf de l'autre côté bon ben ça
s'entretient ce serait à peu près ce à
quoi tu t'attends à ce qu'ils trouvent
un truc que tu divagues et moi j'aurais
vraiment jamais vu où
il ya 15 5 4 il faut croire f4 vous
prend f3 mais bon c'est un leurre c'est
aussi krotoum retrouverait
tu t il trouvé un truc comme ça car en
scène étudiée au cas il a gagné puisque
il a il a joué le truc que personne
n'aurait vu
pour le moment la partie face à
l'impression avec c'est une partie de
deux joueurs à 2005
en dehors de la prépa ouais
on la prépare être impressionnante en
dehors la prépa venus à tata travailler
au cot la gagne et tranquille long terme
t'aurais dit veut faire g5 je pense
prendre du roi
georges passé
il peut il peut nommer wade veut la
gagner épisode possède un côté ou de
l'autre votre super shiv
y avait 2-3 dessus assez sûr qu'ils
avaient faim c'est sûr je faisais à 5 à
4 il faisait ce plan là t'es trop
dégoûté de tout kg de brume
c'est sûr que c'était son plan en fait
rien magnus il a vraiment raté une
chance là ce qui lui mettait ça c'était
moins sur l'ordi et a vu comment j'ai
perdu rapidement je rejoins le coup les
prunes en trois coups et c'était déjà
abandon
c'est marrant quand même
toujours dit qu'ils avaient pas assez de
temps c'est parti non ce que tu as entre
checkent s40 climatique cette idée de
jouer les parties parfaites et de et là
on voit qu'ils sont ils sont calmes
timoré par oued avoir à peine trois
heures trente de réflexion pour la
partie c'est vrai que ce
raccourcissement des décadences là
depuis depuis maintenant une centaine
d'années
ça ça nuit ça nuit à la qualité des
parties à la qualité de jeu des
champions et ça on peut pas leur en
vouloir et fabre
1 qui pourrait drainer par
correspondance comme guitar zelder avec
les ordis allumé tout voilà là on aurait
dû veut croire la dame est là ce jour et
ce qu'il crée bien à ça qu'ils
créeraient
enfin moi j'adore voir des beaux échec
mais là la partie aujourd'hui vraiment
ça presse finalement cet acabit jusqu'au
bout
avoir avoir
d'accord en forme à faire correspondre
le champion bat ça existe déjà
championnat du monde par correspondance
sont dorées gratton frais on pourrait
qu'un des partis de temps en temps voulu
commenter où il faut tout le monde une
partie extraordinaire très très fort
à sa note je pars croit cependant
ça a été tenté ça une partie par
correspondance computer à 6 tabasser les
règles computation ne sont plus tard
assists c'est pour ça que la qualité tu
es vraiment au rendez vous
bah oui mais du coup je crois plus trop
en fait et en fait c'est énorme et tu
compares tu joues avec plein de modules
turcotte et modules suivants les
positions pour qu'ils vous bien les
meilleurs coups comme il faut et du coup
tu danses du module en fait ça c'est un
travail d'informaticien oui mais il faut
bien comprendre et bien évaluer les
positions soi même
non c'est un travail de oued le joueur
d'échecs m
et puis tu peux louer des machins dans
le club pour avoir l'ordinateur biens
puissent entrer un c'est hyper
intéressant
non mais c'est tu vas vraiment au fond
des choses
mon père a fait les demi finales du
championnat du monde par correspondance
en 2003 tu vois
ça charles il dit ça
récent vrai c'est un peu de la recherche
recherche fondamentale du jeu d'échecs
quoi c'est intéressant
une ferme du vinage de bitcoin aux
calculs et éclate n'importe qui oui bon
dans ses galettes urines pas de bitcoin
kwa thema l'ata et durera un an je
n'utiliserai pas une seule carte
graphique msi rtx 3090 qua non thema la
taille du rat
aubin